[Musique]
tous 12
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce grand débat
du second tour c'est une tradition de la
république très attendu c'est un moment
important de la vie démocratique bonsoir
laurence ferrari annonce un avis ils
vont soir à tous bonsoir messieurs
bonsoir françois hollande bonsoir merci
de votre participation à ce débat les
français et les françaises qui nous
regardent permettront ainsi de voulu
j'ai à la fois sur vos programmes mais
aussi sur vos personnalités alors ce
débat nous l'animeront dans un souci
bien sûr de stricte équité de stricte
égalité du temps de parole les
chronomètres en font foi et de la plus
grande clarté possible alors voilà un
peu le programme nous avons décidé
d'abord d'aborder les thèmes économiques
la croissance l'emploi le pouvoir
d'achat les comptes publics c'est à dire
le déficit la dette
les impôts ensuite vous parleront
quelques-uns des grands sujets qui ont
été souvent débattu durant cette
campagne du logement à l'éducation en
passant par l'immigration nous
évoquerons ensuite des sujets plus
politiques et notamment les règles de la
vie démocratique
et puis nous évoquerons les sujets
internationaux d'abord quelques mots en
guise d'introduction laurence alors
effectivement avant d'entrer dans le vif
du débat une première question sur votre
état d'esprit à l'un et à l'autre nous
sommes à un moment très important de la
campagne qu'est ce que vous attendez de
ce débat comment est-ce que vous
l'abordez surtout comment est ce que
vous vous sentez à quatre jours du
scrutin je me tourne vers vous françois
hollande pour cette première réponse
puisque le tirage au sort vous êtes
désignée pour parler en premier c'est
donc nicolas sarkozy qui conclura cette
émission monsieur hollande sur le tetra
d'esprit
dimanche les français vont choisir leur
prochain président de la république
cette décision importante grave pour
cinq ans et donc je dois dire ce soir
quel président je serais si les français
m'accordent leur confiance
je serai le président de la justice
parce que nous traversons une crise
grave dur qui frappe notamment les plus
modestes les plus travailleurs ceux qui
sont les plus exposés et donc je veux
que la justice soit au coeur de toutes
les décisions publiques
les privilégiés ont été trop protégé et
donc ce sera la justice fiscale la
justice sociale la justice territoriale
qui inspirera mon action je serai aussi
le président du redressement la france a
décroché le chômage est à un niveau
historique la compétitivité s'est
dégradée et donc je veux être le
président qui redressera la production
l'emploi la croissance ce sera un effort
très long et qui appellera la
mobilisation de tous de tous les acteurs
et c'est pourquoi je veux être aussi le
président du rassemblement
pendant trop d'années les français ont
été opposés systématiquement les uns par
rapport aux autres divisé et donc je
veux les réunir car je considère que
c'est de toutes les forces de la france
dont nous avons besoin
et c'est ainsi que reviendra la
confiance elle est indispensable à
l'action publique la confiance à l'égard
d'un président la confiance à l'égard
d'une politique d'une vision d'une idée
de nous mêmes qui nous permet de
repartir de l'avant c'est le sens du
changement que je propose nicolas
sarkozy votre état d'esprit
qu'attendez-vous de ce débat
j'ai écouté monsieur hollande c'est
assez classique
ce qu'il a dit moi c'est ce que
j'attends du débat c'est que tous ceux
qui nous regardent puisse se faire une
idée à la fin du débat il a dit qu'il
serait un président extraordinaire si
les français le choisissant il
choisissait et que par contre c'est
quand son prédécesseur naturellement
n'était pas un bon président c'est
classique c'est ce qu'on dit à chaque
débat moi je vais autre chose
je veux que ce soit ça soit un moment
d'authenticité où chacun donne sa vérité
et les français en liberté choisissent
pas avec des formules creuses pas avec
des propos entendus où chacun on se
délie ray les qualités qu'on pourrait se
prêter par ailleurs en vérité ce un
choix historique
la france n'a pas le droit à l'erreur
nous ne sommes pas dans une crise
monsieur hollande mais dans des crises
et mon ambition ça serait que à la fin
de ces deux heures tous ceux qui
hésitent tous ceux qui réfléchissent
se disent au moins quel que soit mon
choix j'ai une idée précise des éléments
qui vont permettre de le faire
juste un mot sur le rassemblement
le rassemblement c'est un très beau mot
c'est une très belle idée
mais il faut y mettre des faits
le rassemblement c'est quand on parle au
peuple de france à tous les français je
ne suis pas l'homme d'un parti je ne
parle pas la gauche
ja je me suis adressé à tous les
français pas simplement aux
syndicalistes qui ont parfaitement l'art
ou là à jouer le rassemblement c'est de
parler à tous ceux y compris qu'ils
n'ont pas vos idées parce que lorsqu'on
est président la république on est
président bien sûr de ceux qui ont voté
pour vous mais on est aussi de ceux qui
n'ont pas voté pour vous c'est peut-être
ce qui fait notre différence oui sur le
au peuple de france c'est sans doute ce
qui fait la différence dans l'ensemble
voilà qui est archi si vous me permettez
vous permettez de terrain d'environ
n'est pas terminée je vous laisse nos
ambitions permettait de terminer enfin
je pense que ce débat
doit être ce moment de démocratie
où les français en refermant des visions
se disent on peut aimer l'un on peut
préférer l'autre on prétend d accord
avec ce qu'ils disent mais nous ont pas
menti ils ont pas joué les skill ils ont
été vrai c'est ça notre défi monsieur
hollande être vrai oui chacun a sa
vérité et chacun sera authentique je
n'imagine pas que vous viendrez et vous
ne pouvez pas penser que j'ai ce qui
devrait donc de nous parlerons face à
face directement nous dirons les choses
sans qu'il y ait quelque chose à cacher
à dissimuler mais je veux revenir sur le
rassemblement parce que je pense comme
vous que c'est une notion essentielle
pour notre pays et si vous avez le
sentiment que pendant cinq ans vous avez
rassembler tous les français vous les
avez pas diviser vous les avez pas
opposé vous n'avez pas montré celui-ci
du doigt celle là de certaines distances
alors je voudrais quitus mais je sais
que les français ont eu ce sentiment
d'avoir toujours à être soumis à des
séparations à des clivages moi je parle
de mon côté je suis de gauche je
l'assument vous êtes de droite vous
pouvez l'assumer ou pas mais au-delà de
ce qu'est notre appartenance politique
nous avons le sens je dois avoir le sens
de la réunion de la réconciliation des
français moi je ne distingue pas le vrai
travail du faux les syndicalistes qui me
plaisent et les syndicalistes qui ne me
plaisent pas les organisations
patronales que je veux préféré ou
d'autres non je n'oppose pas les
salariés du privé ou du public je ne
sais pas de savoir qui est naît ici
depuis combien de générations ou qui
habitent là parce que je pense que nous
sommes tous français et que nous devons
nous retrouver dans le même effort dans
la même unité et donc les français
apprécieront vous à partir de ce qu'est
votre bilan et pour ce qui me concerne à
partir de mes propositions alors voilà
et puis on va peut-être passer j'ai
déconné savez monsieur lange et j'ai une
preuve à vous donner de cet esprit de
rassemblement kim a animé pendant cinq
ans
c'est qu'il n'y a jamais de violence
pendant les cinquante dons quinquennat
que je n'ai jamais été amené à retirer
un texte qui aurait blessé ou créer un
climat de guerre civile dans notre pays
je suis depuis bien longtemps le seul
président de la république qui n'est pas
eu à faire face à des manifestations de
masse qui ont obligé à retirer souvenez
vous de monsieur mitterrand et de
l'école libre des millions de gens dans
la rue et monsieur mitterrand avec
sagesse d'ailleurs qui retire
souvenez-vous du cyp2c19 de tant
d'événements de cette nature souvenez
vous de toutes ces réformes avortées
dans l'université où tant de ministres
démissionner pendant cinq ans je n'ai eu
qu'une seule idée en tête qu'il n'y ait
pas de violence et y compris pour une
réforme extrêmement difficile celle des
retraites il ya eu des manifestations
elles se sont passées dans le calme
personne ne s'est senti humilié il n'y a
pas eu de division il n'y a pas eu
d'émeutes il n'y a pas eu de violences
la france dans ces quatre années de
crise à avancer dans un mouvement de
réformes continuent sans aucun blocage y
compris pour le service minimum y
compris pour l'autonomie diversité je
vais vous dire une chose monsieur
hollande c'est une fierté il ya ceux qui
parlent de rassemblement et puis à ceux
qui l'ont fait vivre alors qu'on disait
parce que je pense que ce débat est
intéressant même si nous arriverons au
sujet qui vont maintenant être les
nôtres sont ceux des français mais là
nous sommes sur un point important de
votre bilan vous dites qu'il n'ya pas eu
de violence heureusement et ça tient
aussi aux organisations syndicales à
tous ces mouvements qui se sont créés un
certain nombre de patients qui ont pu
être évité à de nombreux élus locaux
j'allais dire à ces corps intermédiaires
qui ont permis d'apaiser de réconcilier
et d'éviter qu'il y ait et ce n'est
jamais bon violence ou irruption de
manifestations ou de cortège qui peuvent
dégénérer heureusement qu'il y a eu des
partenaires sociaux heureusement qu'il
ya eu des interlocuteurs et puis par
ailleurs vous nous dites j'ai assumé à
cette nombre des réformes difficiles
mais à quel prix pour les français à
quel prix pour les injustices qui ont
été creusé les inégalités qui ont été
aggravées et là aussi c'est aussi parce
que il y avait une opposition qui a été
capable de dire attendons soyons
patients les épreuves viendront celle du
suffrage universel nous avons gagné
toutes les élections intermédiaires cela
pas amené l'opposition à dire qu'elle
avait quelques légitimité que ce soit
pour prétendre mais voilà si un
quinquennat se termine alors qu'il a été
heurté et s'il n'y a pas eu comme vous
dites de violence je pense que le mérite
en revient à toute la société française
je n'ai pas évidemment le seul mérite
mais je ne peux pas être le seul
coupable non plus monsieur hollande je
vous dirai simplement trois exemples
pour vous montrer que l'esprit du
rassemblement
irin toute la société française peut
être à l'exception d'une partie de la
gauche comme monsieur alex cannes
aujourd'hui cet après midi candidat
socialiste dans le 7e arrondissement de
paris compare le rassemblement du
trocadéro d'hyères pour la fête du
travail au congrès de nuremberg s
l'esprit de rassemblement avez-vous
condamné ce propos profondément choquant
je continue quand le syndicat de la
magistrature
des magistrats qui s'engagent pour vous
soutenir en violation de toutes les
règles syndicales et qui prône une
politique judiciaire de laxisme qui est
le contraire de ce qu'attendent les
français est l'esprit de rassemblement
et enfin quand le leader du premier
syndicat français la cgt appelle à voter
pour le candidat socialiste en violation
de toutes les traditions syndicales s
l'esprit de rassemblement quand on
défile derrière le drapeau rouge avec la
faucille et marteau est ce que c'est
l'esprit de rassemblement est-ce que
vous ne croyez pas que même si on n'est
pas de gauche ont une légitimité à
donner son opinion est ce que vous
croyez que c'est l'esprit de
rassemblement donner des leçons de
légitimité aux uns comme aux autres est
ce que vous avez entendu un propos
d'exclusion quand il eut un propos
désagréables à l'endroit de quelqu'un
qui vous est proche les condamnés à la
télévision quand on m'a comparé à franco
la péta à laval et pourquoi pas hitler
vous n'avez pas dit un mot c'est pas
vrai ce que dans l'esprit des gens à la
mort et ensuite je termine un cercueil
je vous laisse j'ai des choses que je
réalise aller plus loin ce que je peux
aller plus loin je vous manquez de
respect je dis simplement que quand
certains de ses amis tiennent des propos
de cette nature que madame aubry me
traite de madoff 183 ans de prison et
que le leader de la famille ne dit rien
c'est qu'il cautionne et quand on
cautionne des outrances c'est qu'on a
tort c'est qu'on n'a pas la force pour
les dénoncer monsieur sarkozy vous aurez
du mal à passer pour une victime et pour
ryan you est-ce que d'anciens j dilla
quelques je ne vous ai pas interrompu je
vais moi même évoquer tout ce qui a été
dit sur vous allez-y que je suis vous
volez dit on en restera là où vos amis
vos propres amis m'ont comparé à je ne
sais quel bestiaire j'ai eu droit à tous
les animaux des eaux j'ai eu droit à
toutes les comparaisons les moins
flatteuse j'ai été attaqué sur tout
sujet et vous pensez que je pense que
j'ai imaginé que c'était vous qui a
inspiré ses propos vous avez évoqué même
le procès staliniens comme si staline
avait grand chose à voir avec nos propos
donc moi je condamne tous les excès je
considère que quand on est face à face
comme nous le sommes nous pouvons aller
directement à vos bilans vos
propositions à mes projets sans qu'il
soit besoin de jouer les victimes juste
et franchement je vous ai mis devant ce
cas était votre responsabilité de
président nous sortons de cinq ans où la
france a été heurtée où la france a été
divisé où la france a souffert d'un
certain de paroles qui ont été
prononcées pas par beaulieu temps
souvent par vous vous le faites encore
une fois - est-ce que je me suis plaint
que la présidente du patronat français
et dit que vous aviez fait un boulot
extraordinaire et que moi mes
propositions n'étaient pas bonnes mais
moi je considère elle est tout à fait
dans son rôle dans son droit je ne vais
pas lui chercher querelle donc dire que
j'allais terminer dirais que j'aidais
prêtait aussi chez les machins paraît
bonne dose y pense oh non mais c'est
l'extraordinaire que vous avez fait
ordinaire de le dire et donc vous ne
pouvez pas empêcher les uns les autres
d'appeler à voter pour moi et ce n'est
pas
faire un transgression par rapport à ce
qu'est leur devoir démocratique que de
le faire mais enfin voilà vous avez
souvent dur est passé à pelé n'a pas
passé aux théories de victimes moi je
pense que le président idriss et
françois hollande étaient remis les
français des rapports avant pour nous
nous y viendrons monsieur l'on nous y
viendrons alors mais dans un débat de
cette nature
vous me permettrez de vous dire qui a
suffisamment difficultés dans notre pays
il ya suffisamment de choses que j'ai
réussi ou pas réussi
pour qu'on n'ait pas besoin d'ajouter
l'outrance et le mensonge donc le mieux
c'est que nous rentrions dossier après
dossier pourquoi les offenses à londres
à l'instant puisque le débat vient
d'entamer vous êtes à peu près à égalité
de temps de parole le premier chapitre
que nous allons aborder concerne le
volet d économie et social on va parler
beaucoup de choses mais la première
préoccupation des français c'est
l'emploi le chômage a augmenté pour le
onzième mois consécutif
comment peut-on relancer l'emploi en
france et c'est totalement liés comment
fait-on pour renouer avec la croissance
qui est synonyme d'emplois françois
hollande quelles sont vos solutions
avez-vous des objectifs chiffrés ou des
objectifs dans le temps pour faire
refluer le chômage
le chômage a augmenté si on prend
l'ensemble des personnes inscrites
d'amelio c'est à dire quatre millions de
personnes sont inscrites même si elles
n'ont pas
chacune aucune activité si on prend les
personnes qui n'ont aucune activité il
ya trois millions de chômeurs dans notre
pays c'est une augmentation de 7 sur 10
c'est beaucoup ces normes c'est un
record donc
nicolas sarkozy vous aviez dit c'était
en 2007 que si le chômage de tomber pas
5% de la population active vous
considérez que c'est un échec c'est un
échec vous pourrez dire j'ai une excuse
la crise elle est la personne de la
comtesse mais enfin le chômage a plus
augmenté en france qu'il n'a augmenté en
allemagne il est de 6 et demi pour cent
de la population active nous sommes à 10
qu'est ce que je vais arriver aux
solutions il faut de la croissance j'y
reviendrai aussi bien en europe qu'en
france il nous faut de la production et
donc la première exigence à sera de
relancer la production dans notre pays
puisque la l'industrie a été abandonné
quatre cent mille emplois ont été perdus
je créerai une banque publique
d'investissement pour accompagner le
développement des entreprises je
mobiliserai les pagnes des ménages pour
l'affecter au financement des
investissements notamment des pme je
modifierai la fiscalité des entreprises
pour que le bénéfice qui est réinvesti
dans la société soit moins fiscalisés
que le bénéfice qui est distribué aux
actionnaires et puis j'ai une mesure
mais elle ne peut pas être la solution
mais elle est l'idée la plus nouvelle
qui est venu dans cette campagne le
contrat de génération aujourd'hui que
constate-t-on ce sont les seniors qui
sont les plus affectés par le chômage
c'est eux qui sont les premières
victimes des plans sociaux et les jeunes
qui ne parviennent pas eu à rentrer avec
un contrat à durée indéterminée dans
l'entreprise donc la proposition que
j'ai faite c'est que l'employeur qui
gardera le senior le temps qu'ils
puissent partir à la retraite et donc
avec ces droits qui lui donneront une
pension à taux plein
et qui embauchera un jeune avec un
contrat à durée indéterminée cet
employeur là ne paiera plus de
cotisations sociales sur les deux
emplois celui du seigneur celui du jeu
ça réconcilie les âges ça permet de
transmettre l'expérience ça évite que
nous ayons une mesure pour les jeunes
qui se traduit par une mesure en
défaveur des seniors ou inversement donc
c'est la mesure qui dote de la
solidarité qui donne de la clarté et qui
permet d'arriver à ce que les
entreprises souhaitent inciter à avoir
des jeunes en contrat à durée
indéterminée et a gardé des seniors
nicolas sarkozy bon vous me permettrez
de revenir sur les chiffres que vous
savez donner monsieur landi sont fous et
je vous en donne la preuve prenons les
chiffres parce que c'est important pour
ceux qui nous écoutent dubé it et c'est
un chiffre incontestable le chômage a
augmenté de 4 122 milles ce qui est trop
entre 2007 et 2011 schiff des idées
c'est à dire une augmentation de 18,7
pour cent les mêmes chiffres puisque les
chiffres du bit et laurence ferrari
permettent de comparer avec tous les
autres pays sur la même période avec le
même critère du pays de chômage a
augmenté de 18% virgule 7 en france sur
la même période ils augmentaient 37% du
déni de 60% en angleterre
291% en espagne après sept années de
socialisme deux sans trois pour cent aux
états-unis et dans la moyenne des pays
de la zone euro dans la moyenne le
chômage a augmenté de 39 6% c'est-à-dire
exactement le doubs je ne glorifie pas
d'une augmentation de 18,7 je dis
simplement que je me demande pourquoi
monsieur hollande qui veut prétendre à
diriger la france doivent absolument
pour dire du mal de moi
minimiser les résultats de la france
nous avons un taux de chômage qui a
augmenté deux fois moins que nos
partenaires de la zone euro il est vrai
qu'en allemagne il a moins augmenté
pourquoi parce que dans le même temps il
ya dix ans nous faisions seul contre le
reste du monde les 35 heures le
chancelier schröder
par ailleurs soutenu ma candidature
faisait les accords compétitivité emploi
la tva de localisation et toutes les
réformes qu'aujourd'hui vous refusez ça
c'est pour le bilan un mot sur vos
propositions vous allez créer une bonne
public formidable existe déjà la banque
publique de l'industrie filiale d'oseo
existe déjà voilà une promesse monsieur
hollande si vous êtes élu que vous
n'aurez pas de mal à tenir puisque je
les ai déjà fait sur le contrat de
génération c'est sans doute un point
intéressant de différence entre nous
voilà donc que vous allez mobiliser des
fonds publics pour exonérer de
cotisations sociales patronales des
emplois qui existent parce que la
personne qui à 57 ou 58 inquiet dans
l'entreprise et les déjà embauché et
vous voulez mobiliser de l'argent pour
conforter cet emploi je veux mobiliser
l'argent public pas pour ceux qui ont
déjà un emploi pour ceux qui en ont
besoin d'un et figurez-vous je vais vous
étonner je suis d'accord avec ça avec
martine aubry qui dans les primaires
socialistes critiquer violemment votre
contrat de génération en disant quelle
absurdité sic ça va créer un effet
d'aubaine considérable pourquoi donc
faire des impôts est exonérée de
cotisations un emploi qui est déjà créée
dans une entreprise qui fonctionne mais
solutions pour l'avenir pour l'avenir
premièrement il ya un gigantesque
problème de coût du travail savez vous
quelles sont nos deux déficits de
balance commerciale la chine 22
milliards et l'allemagne
l'allemagne est à la fois notre premier
client et premier fournisseur nous avons
un problème de coût du travail pour
éviter le cancer des délocalisations
pour penser à ces ouvriers qui vivent la
peur au ventre parce qu'ils ont peur que
leur usine ferme il faut que le travail
qui se délocalise ne se délocalisent
plus et pour cela il faut alléger le
coût du travail c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai proposé d'exonérer toutes
les entreprises des 5,4 pour cent de
cotisation familiale pour que le travail
coûte moins cher et que nos pulsions le
garder j'avais fait d'ailleurs la même
chose avec la taxe professionnelle la
taxe professionnelle n'existait plus
qu'en france nous l'avons supprimés elle
pèse pour 250 euros par voiture produite
en france deuxième remarque un
gigantesque effort de formation pour que
les chômeurs d'aujourd'hui soient formés
pour les emplois de demain et pas pour
les emplois d'hyères troisième élément
l'innovation ce que nous avons fait avec
le crédit impôt recherche et l'emprunt
de 36 milliards d'euros pour favoriser
l'investissement
et les investissements d'avenir
l'innovation dans toutes nos entreprises
au fond le mot clé c'est le mot
compétitivité
notre réponse qui se regardent d'abord
sur les chiffres je comprends que ça ne
vous fasse pas plaisir d'ailleurs cela
qui a fait le moins plaisir sur les
chômeurs eux mêmes et une bonne partie
nous regardent et se disent que leur
situation s'est dégradée depuis que vous
êtes aux responsabilités du pays il y à
bien 4 millions de personnes qui sont
inscrites à pôle emploi c'est
incontestable il y en avait 3 millions
au moment où vous avez été élu vous
aviez vous même vous êtes passés un peu
rapidement sur votre objectif dit qu'il
y aurait 5 % de la population active qui
seraient au chômage à la fin de votre
quinquennat nous sommes à dix le double
bon alors après vous fait des
comparaisons avec l'allemagne votre
comparaison est impitoyable nous avons
reculé c'est à dire que nous notre
chômage a augmenté notre compétitivité
s'est dégradée et l'allemagne fait dans
tous domaines mieux que nous alors
ensuite vous dites nous dit ah mais
c'est pas de chance c'est à cause des 35
heures est-ce que je dois vous rappeler
nicolas sarkozy que vous êtes au pouvoir
depuis dix ans dix ans pas simplement
cinq ans comme président de la
république et vous étiez 5 ans ministre
sous jacques chirac dont une partie
comme ministre de l'économie et des
finances donc le résultat de la
compétitivité jamais notre déficit
commercial n'a été aussi déséquilibré
jamais 70 milliards d'euros c'est pas la
faute à lionel jospin il ya dix ans ou
quand vous le faites aussi souvent à
françois mitterrand au début des années
80 c'est votre participation à la
responsabilité du pays alors maintenant
vous dites mais j'ai trouvé la solution
j'ai mis du temps passe la tva sociale j
avais songé au début de mon quinquennat
2007 j'avais renoncé je ne sais pas
pourquoi mais en tout cas ça revient à
la fin et ça va nous permettre de sauver
des emplois mais j'ai regardé votre
proposition tva sociale 13 milliards
d'euros qui va d'ailleurs être pas levé
sur tout les français 300 euros de moins
sur leur pouvoir d'achat ce qui va bien
entendu des gradés la croissance mais
vous dites ça va améliorer la
compétitivité des entreprises exposées à
la concurrence internationale
l'industrie elle ne touchera de ces
allègements de cotisations sociales sur
la famille que 3 milliards d'euros le
reste vous savez qui touche les
allègements de cotisations sociales les
services pour 8 milliards la banque les
banques pour 700 millions d'euros trois
fois plus que l'industrie automobile
dont vous avez parlé donc ça veut dire
que vous inventez une taxe nouvelle sur
les français qui va prélever sur leur
consommation affaibli à la croissance
pour avoir un effet sur les entreprises
industrielles de très faible ampleur et
donner un cadeau supplémentaire aux
entreprises de services allez comprendre
et enfin vous nous dites formation est
tous d'accord sur la formation 10%
seulement 10 % des demandeurs d'emploi
de notre pays et vous êtes président de
la république donc 10 % des demandeurs
d'emploi se voit proposer une formation
vous dites maintenant je vais leur
proposer et il est bien temps qu'avez
vous fait depuis cinq ans pour les
laisser sans formation et sans
qualification alors nicolas sarkozy puis
on va avancer un peu dans le débat je
vais vous répondre très précisément
monsieur hollande parce que ce débat ait
tellement important qu'il ne souffre
aucun mensonge et aucune précision
d'ailleurs vous admettrez qu'entre 2007
et 2012 j'ai eu quatre années de crise
et vous admettrez certainement que
j'étais pas au pouvoir aux etats-unis en
espagne en italie et ailleurs vous
parlez de l'allemagne
considérez-vous donc maintenant que
l'allemagne après l'avoir tant critique
est un exemple ça m'intéresse pourquoi
l'allemagne fait mieux que nous
l'allemagne est elle fait les 35 heures
l'allemagne a fait le contraire de la
politique que vous proposer aux français
l'allemagne a fait la tva
antidélocalisation que je propose trois
points vous la refusez l'avant vers
l'allemagne ce n'est pas vrai monsieur
lentilles pas concédant malkin ont
protesté après la tva antidélocalisation
qu'on termine en allemagne n'était que
d'un point l'allemagne a fait la tva
anti délocalisation de trois points elle
en a affecté un point aux réductions de
charges et les autres la réduction du
déficit est la deuxième point fait la
règle d'or que vous refusez troisième
point elle fait les accords
compétitivité emploi que vous refusez
c'est à dire la possibilité pour les
salariés les chefs d'entreprise de
discuter durée de travail et salaires
dans l'entreprise l'allemagne que vous
cité en exemple pour accabler mon bilan
monsieur hollande fait le contraire de
la politique que vous proposer aux
français je veux m'inspirer de ce qui
marche pas de ce qui marche pas pour moi
l'exemple à suivre c'est plutôt sud
l'allemagne que sud la grèce ont celui
de l'espagne donc je crains que cet
argument se retourne violemment contre
vous
troisième élément vous parler du déficit
comme de la balance commerciale il est
de 70 milliards c'est exact savez-vous
pour combien pèses l'énergie fossile
dans les 70 milliards de déficit le
savez vous oui oui je ne sais mais dit
le savez si vous savez où espère donc
d'un jeu si vous le savez vous le dites
c'est 63 milliards vous savez que ça
remet toujours peser nous dans le
commerce explique puisque il ya toujours
eu un prix du pétrole qui a été élevé
les plus en ce moment mais ils n'ont su
hollande en enlevant sur des référés du
prix du pétrole vous avez le défi
ciation du commerciaux intérieur nicolas
sarkozy vermine je vais me permettre de
vous apprendre quelques jeunes on veut
nous voulons bien mes jambes sont
nicolas sarkozy très respectueusement
puisque vous le connaissent a dit pas
vous connaissez le chiffre de 70
milliards et vous ignoriez mais pas du
tout que sur les 70 là pour nous dire ce
que je sais tout je ne sais pas mais
c'est pas vous qui posez les questions
et c'est pas vous qui donnait les notes
dans 7 des jeunes donnent aucune note
mais quand vous vous trompez le juge
aurait faire vous le dire 63 milliards
vient du coût des énergies fossiles mais
mieux que ça savez vous que ces 63
milliards c'est 35 % de plus par rapport
à l'année dernière je pense d'ailleurs
qu'il est totalement
irresponsable dans la situation 63
milliards de notre déficit pèse sur le
coût de l'énergie étaient de plus en
plus cher de vouloir casser la filière
nucléaire est il vraiment le moment pour
la compétitivité de notre industrie
d'attendre le prix du pétrole et le prix
du gaz le plus élevé jamais connu pour
supprimer le nucléaire on a prévu d'en
parler un peu plus tard mais pardon
enfin deux derbies remarques sur la tv
la tv appel pèsera sur les importations
les eee pad que vous avez offert à tous
les enfants de corrèze ont tous été
fabriqués en chine parce que y'en a pas
un seul qui se fabrique en france quand
on augmente l'importation ça veut dire
que désormais ce qui fabriquons des
ordinateurs des écrans plats des eee pad
à l'extérieur participeront au
financement de notre projet social vois
vraiment pas pourquoi on va l'économiser
jo donné deux chiffres avec ce que je
propose et qui rentrera en vigueur au
1er octobre
94 % des employés agricoles
94% ont 10 800 euros de cotisation -
65 % des ouvriers des employés de
l'industrie
soixante dix huit pour cent des ouvriers
de l'industrie automobile voilà les
chiffres ils sont incontestables enfin
dernier mot sur cd pour cent de chômeurs
c'est exact c'est un chiffre exact
violents qui sont formés mais savez vous
pourquoi parce que la compétence de
formation est aujourd'hui partagée entre
les syndicats les régions et l'état pôle
emploi l'état verse aux régions 5
milliards 4 pour payer la formation
savez-vous l'année dernière sur les 5
milliards cas de crédits de formation
versée par l'état pour la formation
professionnelle à disposition des
régions savez vous combien ont été
dépensés 4 vous croyez vraiment que
c'est la faute de l'état simplement je
pense qu'il faut un changement
considérable considérable pour que la
formation aille à ceux qui en ont besoin
notamment aux chômeurs parce que le
drame c'est pas simplement de perdre son
emploi c'est la certitude dans laquelle
on se trouve
de ne pas pouvoir
retrouvez un parce qu'on ne vous offre
pas la formation dont vous avez besoin
de réponses rapides monsieur hollande
êtes quasiment à égalité de temps et il
faut qu'on parle du pouvoir d'achat mais
on parlera de tout cela mon nez sur le
thème du pouvoir d'achat mais avec vous
c'est très simple ce n'est jamais de
votre faute vous avez toujours un bouc
émissaire là vous avez dit ce sont les
régions ce n'est pas moi la formation je
n'y peux rien sur le chômage ce n'est
pas moi c'est la crise qui nous a
frappés sur l'allemagne qu'est ce que
vous voulez j'ai mis cinq ans avant de
comprendre quel était le modèle allemand
avant j'avais le modèle en donc aux
gosses action à l'esprit ce n'est jamais
de votre faute vous aviez 10 5% de
chômage c'est 10 % de taux de chômage ce
n'est pas de votre faute c'est la faute
à la crise jamais vous et puis vous dit
vous avez vous remercie d'avoir incité
les eee pad que je mets à distribution à
tous les collégiens de corrèze je vous
en remercie mais
comprenez bien que lorsque un prix d'un
produit est relevé que ce produit est
acheté par le consommateur c'est bien un
prélèvement sur le consommateur il n'y a
pas de substitution par rapport à un
produit français est donc cette tva que
vous allez imposée elle va prélever du
pouvoir d'achat j'ai fait le calcul 300
euros pour un couple de smicards voilà
ce que va être le prélèvement annuel que
vous allez infligée pour une baisse de
cotisations dont j'ai dit que seuls 3
milliards vont être affectés à
l'industrie donc à ce qui peut nous
relever dans le commerce extérieur vous
avez voulu faire des chiffres du
commerce extérieur un élément de
polémique mais vous vous trompez corps y
en a juste pas à quitter la responsable
études pays en 2002 il y avait déjà un
prix du pétrole il y avait déjà un
pétrole cher les comptes extérieurs de
la france était équilibré aujourd'hui
les comptes extérieurs de la france sont
déficitaires de 70 milliards avec une
facture pétrolière qui a sensiblement
augmenté mais pas plus de 30% donc
notre déficit du commerce extérieur est
d'ailleurs structurelles ça fait cinq
ans cinq ans qu'il s'est accru chaque
année donc voilà le bilan alors
maintenant sur la compétitivité qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire de mieux mais il ya
l'innovation il ya l'investissement et
pas simplement la baisse du coût du
travail vous dites les accords
compétitivité emploi la belle idée que
vous avez lancé sauf que ça va avoir
comme conséquence qu'il n'y aura plus de
durée légale de travail puisque
employeurs et partenaires sociaux qui se
mettront d'accord j'en conviens dans une
entreprise considérons qu'il n'y a plus
de durée légale du travail plus d'heures
supplémentaires mais simplement un
arrangement donc on va là aussi un
démantèlement d'un principe qui était
celui de la durée légale du travail
alors réponse sur ce point et puis on
change de chapitres peut-être quand vous
en êtes d'accord monsieur landau peut me
reprocher bien des choses et je le
comprends bien pape pas assumer mes
responsabilités voyez vous on m'a même
reproché le contraire
j'ai toujours assumé mes responsabilités
et je considère que c'est normal quand
on est président de la république
si la tva anti délocalisation était si
mauvaise idée on se demande bien
pourquoi votre propre porte parole
manuel valls on a fait le thème de sa
campagne dans les primaires socialistes
puisque j'ai entendu manuel valls
aujourd'hui votre propre porte parole
dire que la tva antidélocalisation
c'était la solution et la véraison
j'ajoute que je ne vois pas comment
monsieur hollande vous pouvez dire
l'allemagne fait mieux que nous mais on
va prendre aucune des mesures capri
l'allemagne pour réussir l'allemagne a
pris la tva anti délocalisation
l'allemagne a pris les accords
compétitivité emploi mais je vais dire
un mot là-dessus les accords
compétitivité emploi fonction qui nous
regardent comprennent ce dont il s'agit
nous nous avons une tradition fixe par
la loi et ça tue tout le dialogue l'idée
c'est de garder une loi à partir de 35
heures ça sera les heures
supplémentaires
mais si dans l'entreprise
salariés et chefs d'entreprise se
mettent d'accord pour augmenter les
salaires vont augmenter la durée de
travail ou au contraire pour réduire la
durée de travail parce que le carnet de
commandes va pas l'accord dans
l'entreprise prime sur la loi et sur le
contre 1,10 ça s'appelle monsieur
hollande faire confiance ça s'appelle
prendre la responsabilité
ça s'appelle une économie moderne dans
un monde moderne on a par ailleurs une
limite c'est pour arriver à cela il faut
qu'une majorité de salariés le
souhaitent mais au nom de quoi monsieur
hollande on va considérer que c'est
encore la lutte des classes dans les
entreprises que dans une petite
entreprise de 30 août 50 personnes si
les salariés veulent travailler plus
pour gagner davantage s'ils chef
d'entreprise est d'accord ou au
contraire s'il ya un coup dur si le
carnet de commandes diminuent et qu'il
faut que chacun puisse adapter c'est la
loi c'est l'état qui va les empêcher de
se mettre d'accord au nom de quoi et
pourquoi enfin sur monsieur jospin
décidément vous êtes fâché avec les
chiffres ou lettres de la cour des
comptes vous devriez connaître les
chiffres monsieur jospin bénéficier
d'une période de croissance
extraordinaire tant mieux pour lui mais
le commerce extérieur en 2000 et en 2001
il était en déficit net et enfin nord
sur les réchauds donc vous vérifierez
vos chiffres car comme vous dites je
suis de la cour des comptes je vous
remercie de l'avoir appelée et mes
chiffres sont exacts par voulait
vieillir je voulais je voulais je vous
le dis c'est parce que enfin surligne
jacquard en haute et moyenne bien sûr
bien sûr sur l'innovation pourquoi avez
vous voté contre le 'grand emprunt' et
la commission rocard juppé
c'était quoi c'est de l'argent mobilisé
pour l'investissement et pas pour les
dépenses de fonctionnement pourquoi
étiez-vous contre pourquoi avez vous
voté contre la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle alors que ça pèse sur la
production pourquoi venir faire des
grands discours sur ce que vous allez
faire alors pendant cinq ans dans ce que
j'ai fait il y avait des choses dans
lequel vous auriez pu vous reconnaitre
vous avez voté non à tout vous allez
essayer démolir tout vous avez été
contre tout et maintenant vous venez
dire aux français écoutez j'ai changé
d'avis il faut plus d'innovation il faut
plus d'investissements alors l'allemagne
ont fait tout le contraire mais quand
les chiffres de l'allemagne sont bons on
me dit ah bah ça c'est de votre faute
regardez ils font mieux quand je dis b
regardez ce qu'ils font en allemagne on
va essayer de s'en inspirer vous dites
ah bah non c'est parce qu'il faut la
vérité c'est que votre proposition pour
la croissance il n'y a pas un pays au
monde qui fait ce choix c'est plus
d'impôts plus de cotisations plus de
dépenses et plus de différence je n'ai
pas parlé d'impôts de dépenses et de
cotisation c'est quand même un peu mal
mais votre vote
vous la revanche les dans votre
public vous vous l'avez mythe vous
l'avez unis 0 et donc vous n'êtes pas
forcément le mieux autorisés ou le plus
compétent pour de dire comment une
confiance et de la relancer dans le gp
samyn justice n'est pas terminé les le
pays le pays y en a
qui n'a pas connu un trimestre de
récession depuis 2009 c'est la france
oui nous vous avez connu la réassurance
c'est la france vous êtes fait toujours
autant de vies ce qu'est ce qui est
humain ordinaire c'est que quoi qu'il
arrive quoi qu'il se passe vous êtes
contents les français de sondage vous
vous êtes contents et ont vu dois-je
ajouter sur la conscience d'urgence
solaire et que nous a noté que nous
sommes à son et on en reste je dois
accepter pour l'instant je n'ai françois
hollande hier mini puisse justifier
cette expression songe dans lequel ces
deux gars songe le correctement sur
lequel quand vous dites je suis toujours
content avant leur faire est de partir
que l'homme blanc ram responsabilités
c'est un mensonge donc si vous êtes très
mécontent de vous j'ai dû me tromper
j'ai dû faire une erreur je n'entends
que je me suis le maire sa part le
concours d'aller présenter mes excuses
vous êtes très mécontent de monsieur ne
sais pas le concours de la petite blague
non non c'est pas la plage on vous le
dit mais je ne sais pas je ne peux pas
mourir à venir et et en images ne
mentent on essaie on va écouter je vous
dis l'euro c'est une question via le 10
janvier pas il ya capable iliad ild rien
ou quoi que ce soit dans ce lia
direction y at-il donc je ne peux pas
sur la toile ans et c'est chez françois
hollande qui nous répondait en asie
france désagréable venant devrait pas
trop mal y at il un pays au monde
qui a fait mieux y at il un pays
d'europe et de l'oscd qui a fait mieux
en termes de croissance que la france
depuis 2009 il n'y en a pas si les états
unis ont fait mieux que la france en
obtenant de croissance nous n'avons pas
connu et que les imprimés les états unis
un trimestre serait affecté les
etats-unis ont fait mieux que nous en
terme de croissance l'allemagne a fait
mieux que nous en terme de non
l'armagnac hollerich 3% de croissance
nous nos voeux sur l'ensemble de la
période l'allemagne a fait mieux les
etats unis ont fait mieux là c'est donc
sur l'eau s'en voudra dire que la france
s'en soient tirées mieux que les autres
ce n'est pas un jour monsieur la période
est ce que vous êtes à paraître dans
cette querelle police et les états unis
et l'allemagne ont fait mieux sur
l'ensemble de la période c'est certain
mais sur depuis 2009 la france est le
seul pays qui n'a pas connu un trimestre
de récession c'est un fait vous en
rendez compte 300 ya tellement faibles
que nous sommes aujourd'hui à 0,7 quand
les allemands sont à un peu plus de 1 et
quand les américains seront à deux
messages
d'amour je vais quand même nous avons
fait reims est bon mais je vais comme
j'avais annoncé qu'on ferait un set vous
aviez dit c'est un mensonge
il n'y arrivera pas nous avons fait un
choix c'est vous avez toujours c'est
quand même terrible d'avoir dans votre
esprit le mot mensonge comme si c'était
quelque chose que vous ressentez
trépassé vous aider encore de le
remercier vous dans crédible monsieur
alors on me connaît depuis gaza
connaissent ils me l'on vous permettez
que l'on ait cet échange sans qu'il
tombe bien suivante avec des titres et
si vous permettez de parler une seconde
mêlée donc 2011 dsk est exact que vous
ne croyez pas mes prévisions de
croissance mais est-ce que vous est-ce
que c'est exact ou pas mais vos
prévisions de croissance en 2011 devait
être de près de 2 vous les avez ramené à
1,7 c'était plus prudent elle était au
départ de deux je n'y croyais pas c'est
tombé à 1,7 en en chassant si ça devait
être de 1 c'est tombé à 0 7 donc mais
mes prévisions étaient meilleurs que les
votes sur maintenant j'y reviens parce
que vous allez parler des accords de
compétitivité emploi c'est pas la même
chose qui se fait en allemagne est ce
que vous et puis on regarde ce chapitre
c'est qu'en allemagne il y a des
partenaires sociaux ils sont respectés
ce que les organisations syndicales sont
reconnus et qu' il y a une capacité à
permettre l'assouplissement de la vie de
l'entreprise et notamment grâce à un
chômage partiel qui a empêché bien des
licenciements bien des licenciés et
quand l'allemagne fait plusieurs
milliards pour l'aide au chômage partiel
nous en france on a attendu
le mois de janvier pour mettre en place
un mécanisme de chômage partiel donc
vous avez été en retard d'où l'ampleur
du chômage je vais vous dire maintenant
suire toujours le pouvoir sur de la tva
parce que nous y sommes la question de
la tva qui va peser dès le mois
d'octobre sur le pouvoir d'achat des
français et quelles sont les mesures à
6% soit hollande veut que je considère
que 300 euros sur un couple de smicards
c'est inacceptable
mes propositions en termes de pouvoir
d'achat j'y arrive c'est d'abord de
faire en sorte que les salaires puissent
être liés à la croissance et donc
le smic sera indexé non seulement sur
les prix mais sur une part de la
croissance chaque fois que la croissance
c'est les bras le smic sera réajusté le
coup de pouce sur le smic sera donc
fonction de la croissance
deuxièmement je considère qu'aujourd'hui
il ya une part de dépenses contraintes
très élevé nos concitoyens vivent avec
des prix de l'électricité du gaz de
l'eau qui ont considérablement augmenté
et donc j'instaurerai un forfait de base
qui fera que les consommateurs jusqu'à
un certain niveau volume de leurs
consommations paieront le même tarif et
c'est ensuite en fonction de leur propre
consommation qu'il paierait un tarif
super qu'il comprenait progressivité sur
l'essence j'ai dit que il y aurait un
blocage pendant trois mois du prix de
l'essence et l'instauration de la tpp
flottante c'est à dire que l'état ne
pourra pas gagné un seul centime d'euro
sur le prix des carburants aujourd'hui
il ya une tva qui s'applique au prix de
l'essence ce qui fait que chaque fois
que le prix de l'essence augmente l'état
gagne par la tv des recettes
supplémentaires ça ne sera plus le cas
enfin je montrais de 25% l'allocation de
rentrée scolaire dès cet été parce que
je considère que les familles doivent
être soutenus dans ce moment
particulièrement difficile vos solutions
pour pouvoir n'est pas un mot sur eux
les syndicats en allemagne d'abord il
viendrait à l'idée de personne en
allemagne que les syndicats appellent à
voter pour un candidat personne
il n'y a qu'en france cette année on en
voit ça quand les syndicats font de la
politique il ne peut pas défendre les
syndiqués c'est pas vrai parce que
l'allemagne les syndicats sont très liés
au parti social-démocrate vous devriez
le savoir oui c'est pas vrai le pouvoir
d'achat
a permis d'ailleurs aux syndicats d'être
favorable à la règle d'or que vous
contestez deuxième élément sur
le chômage partiel savez vous combien
nous avons financé 2 millions d'heures
de chômage partiel en france
180 millions nous avons financé 180
millions d'heures de chômage partiel les
français doivent le savoir quand le
carnet de commandes dans l'entreprise
diminue au lieu de mettre la personne au
chômage
l'état prend à sa charge avec les
syndicats d'ailleurs le temps de
formation quand la personne ne va pas à
l'usiné ou au bureau parce qu'à pas de
travail monsieur hollande vient de dire
qu'on a été en retard qu'on a rien fait
180 millions d'heures payées c'est plus
d'un milliard d'euros le
pouvoir d'achat la première chose que
nous avons faite c'est les heures
supplémentaires
neuf millions 9 millions de salariés
notre trio ont touché des heures
supplémentaires malgré la crise l'année
dernière
c'est presque 500 euros en moyenne de
pouvoir d'achat en plus neuf payant
puisqu'il ne payent pas d'impôt dessus
et des entreprises ne paye pas de
charges dessus
53 % des ouvriers ont touché ces heures
supplémentaires pourquoi vouloir les
supprimer
parce que quand vous dites on va donner
un coup de pouce au smic combien de
personnes touchent le smic moins de 15%
pourquoi oublier les 85% qui ne touche
pas le smig et vous allez augmenter le
smic donc vous allez
éloignés de l'emploi et de l'entreprise
des gens qui ont déjà tant de mal à s'y
intégrer les heures supplémentaires ont
augmenté le pouvoir d'achat
l'une des mesures de monsieur hollande
c'est de supprimer cela on se demande
pourquoi enfin les deux dernières
mesures tarifs gaz l'électricité alors
voilà maintenant qu'on va payer son
électricité il son gaz en fonction de
son impôt sur le revenu non chez jacques
invasion c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose quand j'ai pas compris parce qu'on
sur la de sa consommation c'est à dire
ça fonctionne et comment cette affaire
va dire que plus vous consommez plus le
tarif s'élève à bon parce que dans votre
projet c'était sur le nord jamais mais
si on les joue pas se venger je voudrais
je serai je serais très heureux parce
que il ya plusieurs projets puis je
viens là car plusieurs fois de
positionna carré
de là votre disposition jeu moi je ne
connais pas le dossier me dois le mien
il est à votre serveur donc dire que
cette mesure va s'appliquer aussi pour
les entreprises et les industries non il
ne s'agit que des ménages ah bon ça ne
s'appliquera pas pour les entreprises
c'est à dire qu'une entreprise
consommera parce qu'elle aura besoin
d'industrie elle elle restera avec le
même niveau mais qu'une famille
nombreuse qui a un appartement plus
grand ou une maison alors lui paiera
plus cher c'est à dire qu'on n'aura pas
le même tarif pour les chasseurs drissa
se présentera en avait pas et c'est par
personne que ça se vend formulera et
quant aux entreprises vous savez très
bien qu'ils ont qu'elles ont des tarifs
pardon venez donc donc il ya une règle
pour les particuliers une règle et c'est
bien ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
particulier consommera plus que plus ça
sera cher mais plus d'entreprises
consommera ça sera pas le même qu'un un
mot sur l'essence le blocage des prix
relève vraiment stupéfiant le blocage
des prix mais vous êtes bloqué quoi
comme prix vous avez pas bloquer le prix
du baril de brent que vous allez acheter
l'arabie saoudite ne méritons ne
l'imaginent avons fait pas de deux là
dessus de digressions c'est pas sur le
prix par sacha du pétrole que nous
allons l'écrire il est sur le marché
c'est sur le prix par de la distribution
de garmisch en voulant raffiné je
voulais en venir là donc vous êtes bien
d'accord que vous allez continuer que
l'état va continuer à acheter du baril
de brent à l'état qu'à chaque culte que
les entreprises restent comparer et
acheter du baril de brent à des prix de
saint céré plus élevée dans quand vous
allez décider administrativement de
bloquer les prix comme si la france
était un îlot isolé du monde qui va
payer qui va payer cette contribuer
parce qu'il ya deux poches monsieur
hollande il n'a pas droit ya la poche du
contribuable où il ya le poche du
consommateur alors retraités en france
où certains mots pour terminer là dessus
2 centimes de moins sur le litre
d'essence c'est un milliard d'euros de
déficit en plus est ce que ça vaut la
peine et ce qui vaut pas mieux mettre en
oeuvre la politique que le gouvernement
a voulu mettre en oeuvre pour aider les
gens à acheter des voitures moins
consommatrices d'essence pour faire des
économies d'énergie enfin je veux dire
une chose quand le prix de l'essence
augmente les gens essayent de consommer
moins donc ça ne rappelle ramène pas
plus au trésor public donc j'aimerais
savoir comment vous allez faire pour
réduire les déficits d'un côté
montella l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire
subventionner le prix de l'essence
augmenté toutes les prestations et vous
faites comment
et puis on passe précisément au déficit
et là encore c'est la méthode que vous
utilisez on voit toutes les prestations
vous ai-je parlé de ça oui je vais
parler de l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire ce n'est pas tout les
prestations vous en conviendrez
deuxièmement sur les carburants vous
vous êtes je ne peux rien je laisse les
français vivre avec ces prix des
carburants qui font que dans des
départements ruraux pour ceux qui vont
leur travail c'est devenu un prélèvement
insupportable et après on s'étonne qu'il
y ait des votes de colère parce que
c'est très difficile de se déplacer
autrement que par son automobile pour
aller à son travail et vous vous dites
moi de toute façon je suis impuissant je
reste là je constate et je mettrai un
peu plus de concurrence et vous avez
utilisés appelés ce deuxième non
monsieur deuxièmement sur les landes sur
les ppp chez lancia cette année sans me
tromper pas parce que c'est je ne fais
pas blesser anxieux malaisie france
relaté ip lait sa flotte vous dites ça
va coûter à l'état mais non ça ne
coûtera pas à l'état puisque l'état
reçoit par la tva une recette
supplémentaire
je veux redire tribu est ce que l'état
récupère sur cet axe enfin le blocage de
trois mois c'est pas une solution
durable mais il faut qu'on y voie clair
quand même sur les mécanismes de
distribution est il normal qu'un
distributeur stocks les carburants
raffinés un certain prix celui qui l'a
achetée au moment sur le marché puis le
vendent avec le prix qui est le prix
effectivement trois mois après le plus
élevé et qu'il prenne une rente non ce
n'est pas normal et donc nous mettrons
au clair les mécanismes de la
distribution c'est pas le contribuable
qui paiera c'est le distributeur qui
aura à supporter finalement ce qui a été
son opacité pour notre messieurs ça fait
cinquante minutes juste un moment c'est
qu'on parle des comptes publics et des
mémés c'est juste un mot pour pour
terminer là dessus parce que c'est je
mets de côté là la remarque sur les les
puissants la meilleure économie
d'énergie monsieur l'on sait l'économie
d'énergie laisser à penser aux français
que le prix du pétrole et le prix du gaz
va pouvoir diminuer et qu'on va pouvoir
bloquer les prix il n'y a pas un pays au
monde qui réagit comme ça d'un seul et
naturellement c'est le contribuable qui
paiera naturellement si le contribuable
qui paiera cette démagogie mais je
répète une question grâce au nucléaire
nous payons l'électricité et le
chauffage 35 % moins cher est il
vraiment en conscience d'après vous est
ce que c'est vraiment le moment alors
que le prix du pétrole explose le prix
du gaz est close est elle vraiment le
moment de vouloir démanteler l'industrie
nucléaire de vouloir fermer la moitié
des réacteurs nucléaires
ces jugements
n'ont fait pas mal s'il vous plaît le
prochain simple est donc il me papa je
vous en prie ses looks justice pour la
clarté du débat jeudi
la montée d'une
pour la clarté du débat s'il vous plaît
je me sens on parle des finances
publiques on est en économie au public
on va essayer de faire les choses dans
l'ordre j'ai su que la samarie le bon
sens que je termine voilà il répondra
tout à l'heure puisqu'il a reçu le prix
des énergies fossiles non seulement
augmente mais les français doivent le
savoir vont continuer à augmenter alors
la dette et les danses et les publiant
ce n'est pas le moment de démanteler la
keynote et les looks on a du jury lui
clairement quand même mais on parlera du
nucléaire autant qu'il sera nécessaire
mais le prix du gaz lui il a augmenté de
60% pour les consommateurs 60 % mais
bien sûr c'est un prix mais non ces
contrats de long terme s'ils savaient
très bien et dormons dire l'électricité
a augmenté de 20% et il est prévu
qu'elle augmente encore de 30% dans la
loi que vous avez
bien la dette et les déficits ça aussi
c'est un sujet très important vous êtes
tous les deux d'accord avec un
calendrier un peu différent pour arriver
à l'équilibré des comptes publics la
question est de savoir comment on fait
on parlera si vous ne voulez des impôts
dans un instant parlons d'abord des
dépenses de l'état vous vous engagez
tous les deux à les réduire comment
fait-on concrètement où l'état peut-il
faire des économies je regardais temps
de parole vous avez une minute trente de
retard françois hollande si vous qui
commencez si vous ne voulez sur ce sujet
pendant la dette publique elle a
augmenté de 600 milliards d'euros depuis
le début du quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy
et si je fais le compte de la dette
publique depuis 2002 900 milliards
d'euros
elle était de 900 milliards d'euros en
2002 elle est donc passé à 18 cents le
double le double voilà la responsabilité
d'une équipe sortante depuis dix ans la
tête à part le budget de l'éducation que
je mets de côté le premier budget du
pays c'est celui des intérêts de la tête
et donc
nous avons presque autant d'intérêt à
payer chaque année que nous recouvrons
d'impôt sur le revenu c'est considérable
bien sûr qu'il faut arrêter ce processus
il ne tient pas d'ailleurs qu'à la crise
vous nicolas sarkozy vous avez été dès
que les français vous ont choisi en 2007
le premier à vous rendre je me rappelle
sommet de l'eurogroupe pour demander de
ne pas respecter le pacte de stabilité
parce que vous vouliez faire des
avantages fiscaux pour des catégories
auxquelles vous aviez beaucoup promis
dans la campagne présidentielle de 2007
ce que vous avez fait le vote du paquet
fiscal qui a dégradé les comptes publics
puis après la crise s'est rajouté mais
en fait cette dette publique que nous
avons que nous allons honorer parce que
nous allons prendre en charge
effectivement ce qu'est votre héritage
et bien cette dette publique elle est
née à la fois de vaud largesses fiscales
pour les plus favorisés et en même temps
de cette incapacité qui a été la vôtre
de maîtriser la dépense publique comment
la radio salah comment au lard et du mat
nous avons une obligation qui est en
2017 et gelé souscrite cette obligation
de rétablir les comptes publics c'est à
dire d'avoir un équilibre cinq ans ça
représente 90 milliards d'euros défaut
nous ferons 40 milliards de prélèvements
supplémentaires et 50 milliards
d'économies sur la dépense sur
les recettes supplémentaires sur les
seuls ménages
ce sera uniquement les plus hauts
revenus
et les plus grandes fortunes c'est à
dire précisément les catégories qui ont
été les grands bénéficiaires de la
politique que du candidat sortant oui
d'abord les revenus du travail seront
fiscalisés au même titre que les revenus
du capital ou les revenus du capital au
même titre que les revenus du travail
même barème même progressivité sens
raffiné dassin nombre de prélèvements
libératoires les niches fiscales qui ont
été en définitive une façon pour
beaucoup de contribuables aisés
d'échapper à la progressivité de l'impôt
seront plafonnées à 10000 euros
et puis enfin il y aura une tranche
supérieure 150000 euros par part qui
sera à 45% au lieu de 41 % aujourd'hui
ces éléments seront aussi complété par
le rétablissement de l'impôt sur la
fortune parce que quand même avoir été
capable en fin de mandat d'infliger aux
français la tva dite anti délocalisation
mais qui ne dissuadera aucune
délocalisation d'avoir infligé 13
milliards d'euros dessus de prélèvements
supplémentaires et d'avoir accordé un
allègement fiscal sur impôt sur le
revenu de près de 2 milliards d'euros
sans compter le bouclier fiscal qui s'y
ajoute c'est quand même le tout sauf
l'équité et l'égalité donc alors
l'équivalent de ce qui sera prélevé sur
les ménages les plus aisés ça représente
les 13 milliards de la tva qui est
prévue en augmentation au mois de
septembre alors réponse de nicolas
sarkozy sur l'impôt laden fait référence
au marbre après nous avons un juge de
paix qu'est la cour des comptes
j'ai nommé à la tête de la cour des
comptes un de vos proches un député
socialiste vous n'allez pas contesté son
rapport le déficit depuis 2007 augmenté
non pas de 600 milliards mais de 500
milliards première erreur la dette a
augmenté de tisser un lien première
erreur la dette 500 milliards c'est une
erreur monsieur hollande est une erreur
de 100 milliards ça pose question c'est
le che faute et demain tous les
journalistes vers on pourra confirmer
que dit le rapport de la cour des
comptes ya aucun doute si ses seins
sommières le rapport de la cour des
comptes précise
sur les 500 milliards il y en a 250 qui
sont de notre déficit structurel c'est à
dire le produit de 38 années de déficit
budgétaire annuel puisque monsieur
hollande ça fait 38 ans que la france
présente un budget en déficit il compris
à l'époque de monsieur jospin ce sont
les chiffres de la cour des comptes 200
milliards dit la cour des comptes vient
de s'ajouter 250 puce 200 qui sont le
produit de la crise savez vous monsieur
hollande vous guette depuis si longtemps
éloigné des dossiers qu'en 2009 les
recettes de l'impôt sur les bénéfices de
la france ont chuté du jour au lendemain
de 25% et que nous avons garanti sur 100
milliards de transferts de l'état vers
les collectivités territoriales la
stricte égalité d'une année sur l'autre
donc à cour des comptes la cour des
comptes dit que sur les 500 milliards de
dette 450 sont dus à ce qu'il s'était
passé dans déficit structurel avant et
200 sont le produit de la crise c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est la cour des
comptes ensuite venons en au fait
vous dites que vous allez faire des
économies ah bon vous commencez par
promettre aux syndicats de l'éducation
nationale avant la moindre discussion
61 mille postes de fonctionnaires en
plus
alors même qu avec françois fillon nous
avons supprimé cent soixante mille
postes de fonctionnaires vous qui êtes
tellement attaché à la réduction de la
dette et des dépenses comment se fait-il
que vous ne soyez pas d'accord avec la
réduction du nombre de fonctionnaires
qui pèse pour cela moitié du budget de
la nation et que solde en europe vous
allez proposer comme si on en avait pas
assez d'encre et 61 milles de plus
deuxième élément la réforme des
retraites que nous avons mis en oeuvre
avec vous avait contesté
réduit de 20 milliards le déficit de
l'assurance vieillesse vous comprenez
que dans lé déficit de la nation et la
sécurité sociale l'état les
collectivités territoriales
vous n'avez pas voté quel père la vertu
vous faites et vous considérez en plus
qu'il faut revenir sur cette réforme car
vous contestez l'allongement de la durée
de la vie et vous allez augmenter 2 05
points les cotisations payées par les
salariés ce qui va miner leur pouvoir
d'achat et de véro 0.5 point les
cotisations payées par les entreprises
ce divin renforcer la délocalisation
enfin permettez moi de vous dire que
dans votre volonté de démontrer
l'indémontrable vous mentez cet amour
pour ça y est décidément et vous le dire
elle est motif qu'ils devraient pour moi
être insupportable mais qui dans votre
bouche fini par être une habitude
parfait vous avez vraiment super mettez
de la bouche des métaphores nous
permettait de faire des grillades
exprimer ça veut dire que vous avez aimé
attention quelques aubaines ferme est
assez grande et ça vous me permettez que
ce que vous reprochez à donner à laisser
nicolas sarkozy le démon terminée la
france est le seul pays d'europe qui a
gardé l'impôt sur la fortune vous venez
de dire que les supprimer c'est le seul
pays d'europe qui a gardé l'impôt sur la
fortune et la réforme de l'impôt sur la
fortune que j'ai fait je les conduites
intégralement financée par les plus
fortunés puisque ça a été financée par
une augmentation des droits de
succession payer sur les plus hautes
fortunes de 40 à 45% allez dire monsieur
hollande qu'il n'ya plus d'impôt sur la
fortune que nous avons fait des cadeaux
aux riches c'est une calomnie c'est un
mensonge ça vous fait oui parce que là
je sais d'ajouter maintenant la calomnie
le mensonge vous n'êtes pas capable de
tenir ces réseaux sont sans être
désagréable avec nos interlocuteurs et
après vous dites que vous avez reçue pas
semblant c'est ça le mot que vous aviez
d'y aller le tout à l'heure et que vous
n'acceptez pas un objectif
le lait la mise en cause celle où vous
pensez que vous pouvez tout me dire non
non calomnies mensonges mais ça c'est
sans doute dans votre nom dans votre
vocabulaire des compliments non je
prends et que c'est comme je t'aime je
n'ai pas à vous dire ce que vous a dit
de vous monsieur fabius vous savez allez
vous avez toujours un socialiste qui
vous sert de référence à ses chansons
votre méthode vous avez déjà si c'est
martine aubry maintenant manuel valls m
dont laurent fabius est ce que vous
voulez que je vous servent nos vielles
pas le lancer vous qu'il doit y noyer
est ce que vous voulez je vous servent
aussi dans tous les concerts de droite
qui ont dit de dieu parce que je devrais
en avoir pour votre service chien danang
une nouvelle ses jumelles âgées de
voyages ans l'impôt sur la fortune
nous sommes le seul pays d'europe qui
l'avons gardé vos amis socialistes
espagnols vont supprimer vos amis
socialistes allemands l'ont supprimée je
n'ai pas voulu supprimer pourquoi parce
que j'estimais qu'en période de crise il
était normal que ceux qui gagnent
davantage plaît davantage
deuxièmement la réforme que nous avons
faits qui a été intégralement financée
par l'augmentation des prélèvements sur
les revenus vous proposez les
prélèvements de l'épargné et des
prélèvements du travail soient les mêmes
nous l'avons déjà fait nous l'avons déjà
fait et enfin dernier point sur le
paquet fiscal
93% du paquet fiscal
93%
c'est pour les classes populaires et les
classes moyennes alors rez-de-chaussée
de ce prix juste et j'en ai terminé
quatre milliards et demi pour les heures
supplémentaires vous croyez que c'est
les riches qui profitent des heures
supplémentaires
3 milliards pour la suppression de
l'impôt sur les successions pour les
petites et moyennes succession parce que
moi j'estime que quelqu'un qui a
travaillé toute sa vie il est
parfaitement normal quand il indique
patrick mois nous un patrimoine moyen
qui le laisse à ses enfants en franchise
d'impôt et enfin je n'ai pas entendu une
économie que vous proposez une seule une
seule
et notamment sur les créations de postes
de fonctionnaires alors sur la blu ray
les écoliers sur un certain nombre de
points
d'abord vous avez inventé
le bouclier fiscal qui est elle y est
d'ailleurs bien si mashiro quartiers
nord qui étaient pour partie déjà
introduit par monsieur villepin et avant
lui monsieur nord regard sur le fleuve
regard mais je vais lui dire vous avez
été capable donc de faire ce paquet
fiscal le bouclier fiscal est donc de
permettre que des plus fortunés
contribuables reçoivent un chèque du
trésor public
chaque année je veux pas citer les noms
vous les connaissez ce sont vos proches
donc il y a un jeu d'échecs de trésor
public qui vouliez ont été adressée à
monsieur le grandes fortunes de notre
pays donc lesquels proches monsieur
hollande on vous savez que madame
bettencourt a été notamment monsieur r
de rihanna
je n'en sais rien chez bigas si vous
avez des informations sur ce qu'ils ont
moi je n'avais pas monsieur ou madame
bettencourt ces faits démontrés chanter
j'ai des informations sur les moyens si
vous avez des ravages et offrit sicard
gens que je ne connais pas moi je n'ai
pas la disposition de vos emails mais
vous voulez de dingue mais vous avez
donc distribuer des chèques du trésor
public pour les plus grandes fortunes à
travers le bouclier fiscal c'est le
mécanisme qui consiste à verser un
chèque du trésor public à des
contribuables fortunés et bien moi la
politique que je recommande c'est que
les plus grandes fortunes face des
chèques au trésor public ça s'appelle la
justice fiscale deuxièmement sur ce que
vous appelez les postes de
fonctionnaires j'ai effectivement
considérer que dans l'état actuel de
l'école publique
que j'ai
apprécié tout au long de cette campagne
parce que c'est très dur pour les
enseignants et pour les personnels de
l'éducation de vivre ce que vous l'avez
leur avait fait supporter très dur 80
mille suppressions de postes des rased
c'est à dire des réseaux qui est serve
aux enfants les plus en difficulté rayés
de la carte dans les écoles rurales des
suppressions de classes dans les écoles
des quartiers un certain nombre de
soutiens qui sont maintenant au thé
voilà l'état de l'école publique
quatre-vingt mille suppressions de
postes et on a encore 14 mille à la
rentrée qui arrivent et face à ce
désespoir à ce découragement parce qu'en
plus vous avez supprimé l'année de
formation des enseignants considérant
que quand on est enseignant on n'a pas
besoin d'être préparé à ce métier en
plus on en voit ces jeunes enseignants
dans les établissements les plus en
difficulté eh bien oui voilà l'état que
vous laissez de l'éducation nationale
est bien moins devant cette situation
j'ai pris un engagement et je l'assumé
c'est de créer douze mille postes par an
douze mille pour tous les métiers de
l'enseignement c'est à dire pour les
professeurs mais aussi pour les
assistantes sociales pour les
infirmières scolaires pour les
surveillants pour ceux qui vont encadrer
les élèves qui sont les plus en
difficultés les plus violents pour ceux
qui font leurs retrouver une nouvelle
chance oui il y aura 12 il création de
poste ça reprend 12 cents soixante mille
sabords de 500 millions d'euros par an
et à la fin ça reprendra un peu moins de
2 milliards d'euros le chiffre n'est pas
content et on les embauche pour cinq ans
le chiffre n'est pas contestée attendez
que je termine vous les éponger
milliards d'euros 2 milliards d'euros
doit être mis en comparaison doivent
être mis en comparaison avec
l'allègement de l'impôt sur la fortune
que vous vous avez accordé à
l'allègement de l'impôt sur la fortune 2
milliards d'euros et le bouclier fiscal
en sus en 2012 2013 et bien voilà une
différence monsieur sarkozy entre vous
et moi moi je protège les enfants de la
république vous vous protégez les plus
privilégiés c'est votre droit enfin sur
la question des retraites vous avez fait
une réforme qui d'ailleurs ne sera plus
financé à partir de 2017 2018 mais vous
l'avez fait voter elle a ses
inconvénients et elle a ses lourdeurs et
surtout ses injustices la première des
injustices c'est que une femme un homme
qui a commencé à travailler à 18 ans qui
va avoir ses quarante et une années de
cotisation à qui l'on va dire maintenant
c'est plus 60 ans c'est maintenant 62
ans et donc faut en faire 42 ans 43 ans
de travail souvent ceux qui ont commencé
tôt sont conviés les métiers pénibles et
bien moi j'ai considéré que oui pour
cette catégorie là je rétablirai le
départ à 60 ans dès lors qu'il ya
quarante et une années de cotisation et
qu'on a commencé tôt à travailler 5
milliards d'euros et vous avez décrit sa
domination et les cotisations seront
effectivement relevé à la fin du
quinquennat 0,1 pour cent par an jusqu'à
fin 2017 et j'assume là encore ce choix
quant aux économies de dépenses j'ai
pris un certain nombre d'engagements les
effectifs de la fonction publique seront
stabilisés globalement tout au long du
prochain quinquennat et la dépense
publique n'augmentera pas plus de 1% par
an je rappelle que sous votre direction
pendant cinq ans la dépense publique a
augmenté de 2% votre réponse qui on
parle de l'europe bon la france est le
pays d'europe avec la suède qui a les
seins les plus lourds est-ce que vous
avez conscience que nous sommes dans un
monde ouvert
il ya une différence entre nous
vous voulez moins de riches moi je veux
moins de pauvres est à la fois plus de
pauvres et des riches plus riches n'est
pas exact si c'est vrai et c'est pas une
plaisanterie et ce n'est pas une la
france est assurée à la france et en
europe et dans un monde ouvert qu'est ce
que vous voulez monsieur long que tout
le monde s'en aille que plus personne ne
puisse payer des impôts ici la france
est avec la suède le pays où les impôts
sont les plus lourds voulait continuer à
les augmenter ou et faire croire quoi
vous avez défini une personne riche
comme gagnant 4 me leroy alors vous
savez très bien c'est parce que vous
avez dit que c'était pas mon expression
et que vous avez très bien si la série
que j'ai fixé à un million d'euros le
seuil d'imposition des 75% que vous avez
dans l'évadé je prends pas de 75% vous
aviez donc voir aucun moment dans mes
propositions fiscales le seuil de 4000
euros et une dizaine par an je peux
partir la cassure on n'essayait pas de
chercher à richelle que pot limit que ce
soit vous n'y arriverez monsieur vous
qui aimez rassemble et qui avait dit que
je ne vous n'aimez pas les riches et
alors que le journaliste l'interrogeait
11e qu'est ce qu'un riche de 17 à partir
de 4000 euros non jamais si vous voulez
la couple de passionnés là si ce n'est
pas du tout après que j'avais cédé pour
remettre en cause les avantages fiscaux
qui avaient été accordés l'afp par le
gouvernement sur lequel sion journée
dans un monde ouvert oui je vais venir
sur le seo version qu'on est dans un
monde ouvert que les emplois peuvent se
délocaliser que le capital se délocalise
que nous avons les impôts les plus
élevés d'europe avec la suède et que
vous proposez pour financer votre folie
dépensière votre incapacité à dire non
dès qu'un syndicat ou un corps
intermédiaires vous demande quelque
chose une augmentation continue des
impôts je viens sur vos propositions des
jeux les ducs avec monsieur larose et
peut-être même de
très haut niveau des prélèvements
obligatoires vous aviez annoncé en 2007
que vous les baies seriez de quatre
points les prélèvements obligatoires
vous avez de combien ils ont augmenté
sous votre quinquennat on prêt en part
dû perdre donc je n'ai produit à derna
d'horizon monsieur je voulais savoir de
combien de dempster s'il vient dans ce
cas là ce sont les plus modestes qui ont
payé vos donc je voudrais savoir
exactement quel est le niveau des
prélèvements obligatoires puisque vous
monsieur quel est le niveau de ce gâteau
à monsieur hollande monsieur non
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas me reprocher
d'avoir fait des dégâts et de répondre à
ma question essentielle est le niveau
des prélèvements obligatoires
aujourd'hui landes je n'ai pas répondre
à vos calories donc vous devriez pas
répondre je n'ai pas su ou pas répondre
aux questions je veux développer mon
raisonnement contesté vous que nous
avons les impôts il y avait élevé
d'europe contestez vous le contester ou
non mais alors est-ce que vous vous
interrogez part je vais vous dire je
vais répondre donc vous avez augmenter
les prélèvements obligatoires sous votre
quinquennat de près d'un point et demi
nous sommes maintenant à plus de 44 % de
prélèvements obligatoires c'est vous qui
êtes au pouvoir c'est pas moi et vous
l'êtes depuis dix ans et donc quand vous
dites c'est terrible nous avons le
niveau de prélèvements obligatoires l'un
des plus élevés du monde mais c'est pas
à moi qu'il faut en faire la remarque
c'est à vous monsieur ballon qui avait
augmenter les prélèvements obligatoires
ont
rejeté ce que je peux dire un danger
termine ma démonstration souhaitez quand
vous avez transmis vos perspectives de
redressement des finances publiques aux
autorités européennes
vous avez encore ajouté deux points de
prélèvements obligatoires si bien que si
on vous suivez le niveau des
prélèvements obligatoires à la fin de ce
que pourrait être votre prochain
quinquennat si vous étiez réélu serait
supérieur à 46 7 % du pib le plus élevé
du monde réponse de nicolas sarkozy et
on parle de l'europe et du pacte de
stabilité
monsieur hollande face à la crise pour
réduire nos déficits des milieux note en
détenant j'ai dû prendre des décisions
qui ont conduit à renforcer l'imposition
des plus riches non vous avez passé
la première partie de ce débat a
démontré que nous avions fait des
cadeaux aux plus riches et vous venez de
le conclure en disant que j'ai augmenté
les impôts oui des plus modestes c'est
ça votre oeil et bien c'est ça votre
politique c'est que vous avez augmenté
les impôts de tous les français aient
baissé d 1 par rennes convient colasseau
c'est çà et là cela faisait monsieur
hollande supporter que je vous réponde
donc ce raisonnement votre raisonnement
est parfaitement incohérent parce que si
j'ai augmenté les impôts je n'ai pas
fait de cadeaux plus si j'ai su non plus
notamment et notamment parce que j'ai
aligné la fiscalité des revenus
financiers sur les revenus du travail et
en vous à force de vouloir trop
démontrer vous avez démontré exactement
le contraire mais revenons sur
l'éducation nationale
1990 2011 540 mille enfants en moins
dans l'éducation nationale cinq cent
quarante mille ans - nombre de
professeurs a augmenté de 34 milles 12
millions d'enfants scolarisés dans nos
écoles un million d'adultes nous avons
le taux d'encadrement le plus élevé de
l' ocde vous trouvez qu'on a les
résultats qu'on mérite vous trouvez que
tout va bien vous trouvez que les
professeurs sont heureux et que les
enfants sont épanouis dans l'école de la
république vous trouvez qu'on peut pas
faire mieux que le seul problème est un
problème de quantité
le problème c'est un problème de qualité
il faut augmenter la rémunération des
enseignants et si on veut augmenter la
rémunération des enseignants on doit
diminuer leur nombre moins d'enseignants
mieux payés mieux formés ayant 26 eur
d'obligations de service au lieu de 18h
votre proposition de 61000 créations de
postes ne réglera rien au contraire
paupérise rats paupérise re à la
fonction enseignante
vous dites que j'ai supprimer les rased
faux archi faux mais je considère que
les rased c'est pour les cas les plus
graves les rased ce sont des certain
nombre de spécialistes qui vont
s'occuper des enfants
quand les difficultés des petits grands
mais je considère qu'il faut maintenant
donner du temps aux adultes dans les
classes ou professeur dans les classes
pour pouvoir s'occuper des enfants qui
ont des difficultés
18h d'obligations de service au collège
et au lycée je propose d'augmenter de 25
% la rémunération de ses professeurs sur
la base du volontariat pour qu'ils
puissent recevoir les familles s'occuper
de l'enfant tissot loi qui n'arrivent
pas à s'en sortir tout n'est pas une
question de poste vous me dites ah mais
les 61 milles que je crée je vais les
retrouver par économies ailleurs mais
savez-vous que l'éducation nationale
c'est la moitié des effectifs de la
fonction publique donc il va falloir que
vous supprimiez 61 mille postes dans les
autres administrations
je serais intéressé de savoir lesquels
des infirmières médias bien sûr de la
fonction publique d'état
non mais c'est celle publique la
fonction publique hospitalière scénario
léger des policiers moi je veux
augmenter leur nombre ici puisque vous
avez suivi à 12 mille îles et les plus
policiers et les jeunes aussi aux mille
durant votre quinquennat vous étonner
après qu'il y ait de la colère donc vous
serez incapable de trouver le l'économie
incapable et c'est encore une fois le
laxisme et la folie dépensière vous avez
fait ça pour quoi parce que quelques
syndicats voulant demander il n'y a
absolument pas besoin de 61 mille postes
de plus est-ce qu'on en parle et justin
motionnaire art est un beau sur les
retraites c'est la réforme que nous
avons conduite qui met en cause la
pénibilité la pénibilité n'existait pas
d'abord vous dites 18 ans aujourd'hui
une personne qui parle qui a commencé à
travailler avant 18 ans pas la retraite
à 60 ans monsieur hollande part à la
retraite à 60 ans
sur les 750 mille personnes qui partent
à la retraite chaque année il y en a 150
milles qui partent à 60 ans et j'ai
introduit pour la première fois en
france le critère de la pénibilité si
monsieur non lorsqu'on a une
chose ne confondez pas invalidité et
pénibilité si on avait des gueulantes et
c'est parce que le travail est pénible
quand cette invalidité et de 20% le
départ à la retraite à 60 ans et de
droit quand elle et 10% si elle est liée
à une activité professionnelle elle est
possible mais vous rendez compte qu'en
revenant sur cette réforme vous allez
faire payer les salariés ceux qui nous
écoutent doivent savoir que les
milliards 5 milliards de plus vous
l'avez reconnue vous allez leur faire
payer en augmentant leurs cotisations
c'est comme ça que vous aidez pouvoir
d'achat monsieur hollande messieurs on a
compris envers jean ce jeu cotisations
des entrevues revient sur les différents
points nous arrive tous les biens acquis
sociaux par c'est beaucoup ce sujet mais
on est en train d'accumuler du retard
que le jeune cody continuer à développer
des arguments qui ne peuvent pas alors
recevoir mon à gardez vous avez mal
compris
dominion koh lanta pour intel s'émouvoir
talent et si vous voulez que je vous
réponde il faut mieux de ciboulette
jouer et on passe à l'europe première
idée fausse le taux d'encadrement
dans le primaire et le plus bas de
l'oscd eux c'est à dire que nous avons
le moins de professeurs dans le primaire
par rapport aux élèves que dans tous les
pays comparables le moins nous avons
perdu ce qui était pourtant une de nos
forces l'attractivité de l'école
maternelle puisque seulement 10 % des
moins de trois ans sont scolarisés en
maternelle c'est étrange un autre sujet
c'est et 36% y ait dans le primaire nous
avons le taux d'encadrement le plus
faible ensuite sur la formation vous
dites ou veut des enseignants mieux
formés vous avez vous-même votre
gouvernement supprimer purement et
simplement la formation des enseignants
il n'y en a plus ensuite sur ce que vous
proposez aux enseignants voire dit voilà
je vais vous demander le travail et 50%
de plus non plus 18 heures mais 26,1 et
je vais vous payer 25 fonction de bus et
ça sera sur le volontariat est ce que
vous connaissez beaucoup de personnel
qui accepteraient de travailler
50 pour sûr de plus en étant payées 25%
depuis si vous en trouvez vous me le
signaler sur les retraites et je veux
revenir à votre exemple ceux qui ont
commencé à 18 ans et qui ont fait des
métiers pénibles eux seront obligés
d'attendre 62 ans je ne le veux pas et
enfin vous me dites non 15 janvier et
ceux qui ont travaillé avant 18 ans je
parle de ceux qui ont donc à leicester
19 ans 18 ans et plus ou il arrêtait à
caen ceux qui ont 18 ans quarante et une
années ça fait cinquante neuf ans ils
sont obligés d'attendre déjà 60 ans donc
ils vont être obligés d'attendre 62 ans
trois ans de plus je le refuse on a
encore pris une verge à 60 ans sur les
économies parce que je ne veux pas
laisser penser que j'augmente ray la
dépense publique vous vous avez pris la
règle du non remplacement d'un
fonctionnaire sur deux je ne la retient
pas donc il y aura la stabilité des
effectifs de la fonction publique ce qui
veut dire que plutôt que de ne pas
remplacer des fonctionnaires partant à
la retraite moi je ne les remplaceraient
papa tout mais je créerai les poste et
dans l'éducation nationale et dans la
police parce que comment admettre que
dans la police et dans la journée à
maury il y ait pu y avoir 12 mille
suppressions de postes via la zone euro
le pacte de stabilité rennes j'ai juste
passé près son coup d'avancé j'ai juste
trois petites remarques mais elles sont
importantes monsieur hollande me
reproche de proposer une augmentation de
25% pour 50 % d'augmentation des heures
je voudrais lui dire que dans mon esprit
on ne paye pas de la même façon une
heure devant la classe avec 25 ou 30
élèves et une heure de dialogue avec un
élève sur les 26 eur d'obligations de
service par rapport aux 18 heures de 18
heures par semaine huit mois de l'année
je ferai je montrerai les heures de
cours de 18 à 21 heures et de 21 à 26 et
pour l'entretien individuel il normal
que ça ne soit pas payer la même façon
deuxième point sur lie la formation des
maîtres j'ai supprimé les juifs
c'était une catastrophe non vous êtes
formés lorsque l'est sujet la
déformation des noms j'ai supprimé les
arm qui était une catastrophe parce que
j'ai voulu que nos enseignants soient
formés dans les universités enfin une
information pour vous il ya trois cent
soixante quinze mille professeurs aux
primaires pour
282000 classe nous avons un taux
d'encadrement dans le primaire de 23 par
classe il est faux de dire que c'est le
taux le plus bas vous l'avez même le
rouge emblème vous l'avez vous même
reconnu à à tel point que vous avez été
obligé de concéder que vous remplace
seriez désormais dans le primaire les
fonctionnaires partant à la retraite
vous même vous l'avez accéder dès lors
il veut blême de l'igs a provoqué le
corps l'école de pierrick c'est un
problème de qualité de formation et de
la qualité de la rémunération
collaborent d'autres sujets pas long
d'europe voilà parlons un peu de la zone
euro qui a été qui est toujours soumise
à rude épreuve en raison de la crise de
la dette vous êtes d'accord tous les
deux pour soutenir l'euro en revanche
vous affronter sur le pacte budgétaire
européen qui a été signé l'an dernier
qui nous liera pour de nombreuses années
s'il est ratifié françois hollande vous
voulez leur et négocier nicolas sarkozy
vous ne voulez pas ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer pourquoi et aussi nous
préciser quel rôle vous voulez voir
jouer à la banque centrale européenne
françois hollande légèrement en retard
sur le temps de parole et on va vous
réponse à ces brèves parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de sujets et qu'on a beaucoup
de retard s'il vous plaît aux d'abord la
crise de la zone euro ça fait maintenant
près de trois ans qu'elle est ouverte et
il y a eu beaucoup de retard qui a été
pris et on l'a payé très cher au départ
c'était la grèce et ça c'est diffusé à
l'ensemble de la zone euro par effet de
ricochet et nous en payons les
conséquences
la france elle même a été dégradée une
agence sur les trois à dégrader la
signature de la france et c'est
forcément regrettable
il a été signé impact budgétaire
c'était à la fin de l'année elle était
confirmée au mois de mars qui instaure
des disciplines des sanctions pour les
pays qui ne respecteraient pas les
disciplines
comprend qu'il convienne d'instaurer des
règles pour que les pays se mettent en
bonheur des notamment le nom puisqu'il a
été mis en désordre depuis cinq ans
depuis dix ans donc il ya nécessité de
nous remettre dans l'est dans les clous
pour réduire nos déficits mais la rouge
conteste c'est qu'il n'y a eu aucune
dimension de croissance ce qui fait que
n'impose à des pays l'austérité
généralisée
l'espagne le portugal la grèce faut-il
en parler l'italie le nôtre qui subit
aussi une austérité et donc nous serions
condamnés pour toujours à l'austérité
sans d'ailleurs que le niveau des
déficits recul parce que s'il n'y a pas
de croissance il n'y a pas de recettes
supplémentaires et s'il n'a pas de
recette supplémentaire les
déficits ne peuvent pas être réduit donc
j'ai proposé un programme en quatre
points pour la relance de la croissance
premier point que nous puissions créer
enfin ces eurobonds cette capacité
d'emprunt qui serait donnée à l'union
européenne pour qu'elle finance des
projets d'infrastructures des projets
d'économie d'énergie des projets
industriels deuxième point mobiliser la
banque européenne d'investissement
augmenter son capital et faire en sorte
que nous puissions financer l'innovation
la recherche
et un certain nombre de projets que
poursuivre nos collectivités locales
troisième point mobiliser les fonds
structurels qui sont aujourd'hui
inutilisées et quatrième point créer une
taxe sur les transactions financières
d'un certain niveau et qui puisse
permettre d'avoir une ressource
supplémentaire
enfin la banque centrale européenne on
est dans une situation invraisemblable
aujourd'hui on a une banque centrale
européenne qui prêtent sans limite aux
banques un taux d'intérêt de 1% et qui
en définitive ces banques sont laissés
seuls
disposer de cet argent pour venir ou ne
pas venir en soutien aux états et quand
elles y viennent auprès des états
notamment auprès de l'espagne c'est un
taux d'intérêt de 6% qui est demandé la
banque obtient un crédit de la banque
centrale de 1% et le prête à 6% je
refuse alors est donc ce que j'ai
demandé c'est qu' il y ait une
renégociation du traité pour que nous
puissions intégrer
la dimension de croissance je constate
d'ailleurs que depuis que j'ai fait ces
propositions sans doute le premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle a été utile
un certain nombre de chefs d'état et de
gouvernement regardez du côté de la
france le président de la banque
centrale européenne dit il faut revenir
en arrière a ajouté un pacte de
croissance le chef du gouvernement
espagnol qui est de droite mais se dit
je ne peux pas tenir s'il n'y a pas de
croissance le président du gouvernement
néerlandais a la même attitude mario
monti qui n'est pas de ma sensibilité
non plus mais qui est bien conscient que
l'italie ne peut pas vivre en récession
bref je sens les ligues bouger et même
du côté allemand ce plus difficile
notamment sur la banque centrale
européenne ou sur les eurobonds il y à
un nouvel état d'esprit nicolas sarkozy
vous répond l'engagement de venir au
lendemain de l'élection présidentielle
portait ce plan de renégociation et
obtenir ce soutien à la croissance
indispensable et pour nous et koné pour
réduire le chômage et pour la maîtrise
de la terre notre réponse nicolas
sarkozy bon monsieur hollande parle
d'une france qui a été dégradé la france
n'a jamais emprunté aussi peu cher
qu'elle emprunte aujourd'hui
nous empruntons à moins de 3%
ma gestion ne doit pas être désastreuses
que ça parce que le même jour dans les
mêmes conditions l'espagne emprunte au
double sept ans de gouvernement
socialiste pas de réforme des retraites
embauches de fonctionnaires et vous
aviez dit tellement bien de monsieur
zapatero je suis surpris que vous
fassiez cette comparaison
quand je vous faisais je vais pouvoir
féminin mais quand je vous faisais part
choix opposition vous me disais mais
regarde je n'ai pas regardé du côté de
l'espace au moins monsieur zapatero est
un bon socialiser maintenant je fais le
passé ce n'est pas juste je suis à vis
de lui monsieur hollande assure
permettez monsieur zapatero c'est le
seul chef de gouvernement qui vous a
reçu vous vouliez vous inspirer de son
exemple aucun moment quand on voit à
aucun moment nous avons reçu à la
moncloa mais avant de réaliser l'arrêt
madame aubry avait déclaré en 2009 si
monsieur sarkozy faisait la politique de
monsieur zapatero s'est réduit en france
merci elle s'intitulait à l'époque la
zapatera et vous ne pas être brisée une
raccourci qui n'est pas juste votre
premier des gémissements corrigeront
votre premier déplacement fut rien vu
pour l'espagne pour aller en espagne
recueillir le soutien de monsieur
zapatero de vous en expliquer tout le
bien que vous pensiez de sa politique
franchement les français qui nous
regardent aujourd'hui y en at il un seul
qui veut se retrouver dans la situation
de perez bronze en moselle la restons
sur
le pack toujours de votre bilan c'est
quand même curieux qu'à chaque fois vous
allez chercher ailleurs parler de vous
et ça vous gelez de votre politique
répond ménard mais allez-y mais
n'essaient pas de rejouer ici de donner
votre autorisation deuxième point la
croissance bien sûr mais la croissance
ne peut pas être échangé contre la
réduction de nos déficits de nos
dépenses et notre endettement
et personne en europe ne le conteste si
on veut monsieur hollande être
indépendant des marchés financiers des
banques mieux vaut ne pas avoir des
sommes colossales à rembourser quel est
le problème de l'espagne et quel est
l'atout de la france la france avait dit
en 2011 nous serons à 5,7 de déficit
nous sommes à 5,2 grâce aux efforts des
français en a fait mieux l'espagne a
vidé en 2011 nous serons à 6% dé déficit
l'espagne est à 8 la sanction fut
immédiate les banques et les marchés
financiers considèrent que c'est
dangereux de prêter à l'espagne et que
c'est possible de prêter à la france si
on veut retrouver la maîtrise de son
destin on rembourse ses dettes et on
réduit ses dépenses le contraire de la
politique ou compositeur rené bassil
crée alors sur le prêter mais monsieur
lang pardon invente le fil à couper le
beurre il veut une taxe sur les
transactions financières je les fait
voter alors voilà encore n'en sois là
encore non c'est pas vrai mais pas fait
voter la taxe sur les transactions
financières à l'échelle de l'europe
n'était pas vrai pardon excusez moi elle
a été votée en france oui oui ou non et
non non non non vous me permettez là
dessus vous aviez supprimer ce qu'on
appelait le la peau de bourse au
lendemain de votre élection et vous
l'avez rétabli c'est tout ne vous aviez
supprimer un impôt et vous avez rétabli
pour vous n'avez pas créé la taxe sur
les transactions financières landes j'ai
créé la taxe les transactions
financières et c'est la france pardon de
vous le dire j'ai participé à tous les
sommets européens vous ne participez en
juin je peux vous dire quelque chose est
normal et c'est normal et si vous êtes
le président enfin vous avez été le
collaborateur de françois bégin siège au
conseil aura deux septennats il aurait
pu vous confier une responsabilité c'est
le corps qui vous auriez familiariser
avec cela mais sur la taxation des
présidents de la république sont
financières n'ont peut être premier
ministre en cas de cohabitation sur la
taxe financière nous l'avons créée en
france elle rapportera 1 milliard
d'euros et j'ai dit à la minute où nous
obtenons la majorité en europe pour
créer cette taxe financière nous la
ferons donc c'est déjà fait
l'augmentation du capital de l'abbaye
c'est prévu dans le traité
c'est déjà fait la mobilisation des
fonds structurels mais vous inventé le
fil à couper le beurre une nouvelle fois
c'est déjà fait il ya qu un seul point
de désaccord entre nous c'est les
eurobonds ça veut dire quoi vous trouvez
qu'on a passé des tant en france qu il
faut faire monter la dette en europe
mais qui garantira la dette des autres
si ce n'est la france l allemagne leur
bond ça veut dire quoi que nous
financerons nous les allemands et
français la dette des autres je n'en
veux pas parce que j'estime qu'on ne
réduit pas nos dépenses nos déficits et
nos dettes en envoyant en europe des
dettes qui sont garantis partie 6t par
les deux pays les plus forts de l'europe
l'allemagne et la france c'est
irresponsable
enfin dernier point vous me faites à une
critique en disant la la qu'est-ce que
vous avez tardé à résoudre la crise de
l'euro vous croyez que ça a été facile
monsieur hollande vous croyez qu'il
suffit d'arriver avec son petit costume
en disant réglé mettez-vous tous
d'accord vous savez que ces 27 pays en
europe que c'était une crise mondiale
vous pensez que ça a été facile nous
avons évité la disparition de la grèce
ça n'a pas été si facile nous avons
évité l'implosion de l'euro ça a été un
travail considérable qui a été fondée
d'ailleurs sur le couple franco allemand
dont il est irresponsable de vouloir le
mettre en cause quant à la bce ajout
dire une chose je trouve qu'ils ont
plutôt bien travaillé avec les traités
tels qu'ils sont qui ont été négociées
par qui pour ce parce qu'ils ont signés
maïs tritsch je ne suis pas sûr monsieur
hollande que vous auriez fait beaucoup
mieux que nous en lieu et place devant
une succession de crise d'une violence
absolument inouïe messieurs l'europe
sont est sorti et c'est très heureux
pour nous mais c'est très heureux pour
les europe et je vous propose d'écouter
et que dès lors leur on ne s'en est pas
sorti elle est aujourd'hui confrontée à
une possible résurgence de la crise avec
une stricte et généralisée et je ne la
veux pas et si aujourd'hui notre
élection présidentielle est à ce point
regardé par l'ensemble des hôpitaux
publics et au delà des opinions
publiques par les gouvernements c'est
parce qu'il ya un enjeu qui nous dépasse
qui n'est pas simplement de savoir ce
que nous voulons faire en france c'est
de savoir qui va être le prochain
président de la république et s'il va
avoir la volonté de changer
l'orientation de l'europe s'il va avoir
la capacité de faire bouger l'allemagne
ci va voir
l'ampleur nécessaire pour mettre en
place un plan de relance à l'échelle de
l'europe ou de dire on ne peut pas
emprunter à l'échelle de l'europe s'agit
pas de mutualiser la dette des autres il
s'agit de lever un emprunt qui serve à
financer des grands travaux garantie
partir mais garantis par l'union
européenne m hélas si vous l union et là
on vous êtes chez vous gérez la france
là où vous êtes en contradiction c'est
même le président du conseil européen
même le président de la commission
européenne sont sur cette ligne et si
vous vous n'aviez était
libre à tout propos pour mener cette
politique vous l'auriez mener c'est
madame merkel qui vous en a empêchés
je serai une très grande responsable
juste un mot d'abord monsieur hollande
connaît mal l'europe je ne sais pas et
ne sait pas que en europe on ne fait pas
des oukases il suffit pas de dire en
tapant avec son poing sur la table je ne
veux pas il ya des compromis à faire
parce que l'europe c'est justement cela
l'europe de dolor l'europe de monnaie
l'europe de de gaulle c'est le
repoussait sans tendresse comprendre
deuxièmement l'austérité je n'ai pas
voulu en france les pensions de retraite
ont été actualisés les bourses des
étudiants nous avons passé à dix mois
les allocations chômage nous les avons
pas baisser ou l'austérité a frappé
monsieur hollande par tous vos amis
étaient au pouvoir qui n'ont pas pris
les décisions en espagne salaires des
fonctionnaires baisse de 5% retraites
baisse de 4 % en grèce monsieur
papandréou qui vous soutient monsieur
les salaires ont baissé de 21% je n'ai
jamais voulu de l'austérité de la
rigueur en france bien le pouvoir
d'achat des fonctionnaires en france a
augmenté de 10 % c'est enfin un dernier
mot sur le volontarisme monsieur
hollande ne me donner aucune leçon si je
viens
parce que nous sommes moins grave est
qu'il est important il est 22h30 on n'a
pas parlé de la science de l'économie
dit que vous vous savez faire les
compromis no fun à faire des compromis
en l'occurrence par rapport à
l'allemagne vous n'avez pas tenu bon
vous n'avez rien obtenu et par ailleurs
vous me dites moi je suis un héritier de
d'honneur de jean monnet et c'est vous
qui menacé de suspendre votre
participation à certaines négociations
si vous n'obtenez pas satisfaction alors
donc ce qu'elle est dans cette logique
vous seriez pour le compromis dans
certaines circonstances et puis vous
soyez pour la chaise vide dans d'autres
cela ne tient par essieu j'aime / je
suis je termine là dessus deuxièmement
vous avez toujours la volonté de nous né
à l'espagne à la grèce je rappelle une
chose pour la grèce un camp qu'on puisse
penser de ce qu'a fait monsieur
papandréou lorsqu'il a été premier
ministre grec et a fait ce qu'il a pu
c'est il hérité d'un gouvernement
conservateur le pays qui va aussi très
mal c'est l'italie qui a été gouvernée
par un de vos amis silvio berlusconi
pendant des années et donc vous
viendriez nous dire voilà ici il ya des
bons points des mauvais points il ya eu
des gestions qui ont été mauvaises bien
mais il ya eu aussi une europe qui n'a
pas été au rendez vous bien et donc mon
devoir si je deviens le prochain
président de la république c'est de
donner une autre orientation de l'europe
que celle que vous avez subi une minute
de réponse s'il vous plaît et on passe
choisis soit mon ami puisqu'il n'a
semblé souhaiter votre élection je n'ai
rien devenu gagnant pas au niveau robert
non ce n'est pas exact ainsi vous aider
il est bien du pp ou du nucléaire je
n'ai rien ce que dit monsieur valls
connais bien du ppe n'est pas dupe et
brieuc berlusconi berlusconi est
maintenant est-ce qu'il est du pays où
il n'est pas dupe et je n'ai rien obtenu
mais la prod et moi voilà la question je
n'ai rien ne répondez à cette question
sur merci je ne suis pas votre élève
jamais la religion je vous posais j'y
répondrai après vous avoir 10 kg en
hausse jusqu'à 10 mbps sur le même parti
que le vôtre monsieur berlusconi n'est
pas d'homme reparti et il me revient de
loin je n'ai les mots niveau se resserre
dire que je n'ai rien obtenu de
l'allemagne le gouvernement économique
la présidence stable du gouvernement
économique l'allemagne voulait c'était
une demande de la france je ne peux
mettre ça que sur une incompétence
monsieur hollande pas sur la mauvaise
foi deuxième élément je n'ai rien obtenu
de l'allemagne quand la bce prête à 1%
vous en parlais tout à l'heure
en violation de la lettre des traités je
le tenais au sommet strasbourg avec
monsieur menti de l'allemagne pourquoi
rabaisser la france monsieur hollande
rejoint donc à suivre les deux autres de
comprendre à votre personne avec la
france le président de la république
représente la france aux périodes la
formule n'est pas là dans la négociation
internationale vous mais encore je ne
mets pas en cause la france dans la
négociation d'agen dire que je n'ai rien
obtenu de l'allemagne que la france d'un
rien obtenu d'allemagne c'est faux c'est
une contre vérité et une grande
incompétence bien sûr schengen un
dernier mot sur schengen schengen c'est
lorsque schengen ne fonctionne pas et
schengen ne fonctionne pas j'ai dit je
persiste et je signe que si schengen ne
change pas et qu la frontière entre la
grèce et la turquie reste complètement
ouverte nous rétablirons des contrôles
ciblés unilatéralement à nos frontières
quand le général de gaulle a fait la
politique de la chaise vide pour la
politique agricole commune il a obtenu
satisfaction les frontières c'est pas un
grand mot c'est pas un gros mot mais si
nous avons fait schengen c'est pas pour
supprimer les frontières c'est pour que
les frontières soient défendus alors
qu'on choses vraiment vous êtes les
élites égalité de temps de parole donc
on va fermer ce chapitre économique est
passé un certain nombre de sujets de
société - qu'on l'avait prévu sans doute
parce qu'il est déjà 22h30 vous propose
de commencer avec la ligier dans son art
à égalité presque parfaite par un sujet
dont on a pas mal débattu ces derniers
temps l'immigration on n'a pas beaucoup
de temps donc je vous propose de vous
concentrer sur des points précis qui
sont au coeur de vos désaccords
le premier point il concerne ce qu'on
appelle les flux d'immigrés ceux que
nous accueillons sur notre sol vous ne
faites pas le même diagnostic ni vous
n'avez les mêmes objectifs vous
souhaitez nicolas sarkozy réduire ce
nombre d'immigrés vous dit françois
hollande que ce n'est pas la priorité en
tout cas pour la plupart d'entre eux pas
forcément les immigrés économiques
que proposez-vous précisément allez-y
françois hollande
nicolas sarkozy est donc
en responsabilité de l'immigration
depuis 10 au ministre de l'intérieur
puis président de la république
le nombre de personnes rentrant sur
notre territoire en situation légale et
de 200 mille par an deux cent mille par
an c'était 150 milles sous le
gouvernement de lionel jospin donc vous
avez accepté pendant dix ans que rentrer
sur notre territoire pour des raisons
légales 200 mille immigrés
supplémentaires en 2007 quand vous êtes
présentés aux suffrages des français
vous aviez dit sur les 200 milles je
voudrais donner la moitié qu'ils soient
de l'immigration choisie l'immigration
économique
et puis en définitive ce chiffre n'a pas
pu être atteint et l'immigration
économique
tombé à 30 milles au dieu des 100000
attendu et puis là aujourd'hui changer
encore d'objectif et vous dites voilà
maintenant je veux réduire de 200 mille
cinq cent mille le nombre des immigrés
rentrant légalement sur notre territoire
donc qu'est ce que je dis moi
immigration économique je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut la limiter sommes
en situation de chômage croissance
faible il ya des métiers qui pouvait
être tendu je pense qu'aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas avoir plus d'immigration
économique et je fais même une
proposition que chaque année ou
parlement y aura une discussion pour
savoir exactement le nombre que nous
pouvons admettre pour l'immigration
économique étudiants étrangers près 60
milles sur les 180 à 200 milles je suis
pour qu'il y ait des étudiants étrangers
qui viennent apprendre sur notre
territoire et j'ai trouvé regrettable
que monsieur guéant fasse une circulaire
pour rend plus compliquée leur situation
parce que nous avons besoin de ses
talents parce qu'ils vont avec notre
langue développer des savoirs qui nous
seront très précieux ensuite il ya les
demandeurs d'asile nous en recevons un
peu près 50 à 60 pile qui mettent un an
et demi un an et demi avant d'obtenir
une réponse un an et demi je dis peut
pas laisser des familles attendent un an
et demi d'avoir une réponse quand elle
est positive il reste sur notre
territoire quand elle n'est pas positive
il y reste quand même parce que très
difficilement partir donc j'ai dit nous
devrions donner une réponse en six mois
pour les demandeurs d'asile restent
l'immigration familiale et les conjoints
de français
je considère que pour l'immigration
familiale il faut poser des règles sur
un niveau de revenu minimum ce qui
existe déjà et aussi pour les conditions
de logement et la maîtrise du français
sur les conjoints de français c'est là
dessus que vous voulez intervenir je
considère que nous pouvons pas empêcher
un français ou une française qui s'est
marié sauf si ce mariage est contestable
et contestée de faire venir son conjoint
ici donc je considère que l'immigration
légale peut être maîtrisé mais qu'on ne
peut pas fixer des objectifs qui sont
tout à fait hors d'atteinte et ça sera
d'ailleurs la même chose qu'en 2007
quand il s'était agi de l'immigration
économique qui n'a pas du tout et et l
immigration choisie que monsieur sarkozy
avait un moment
imaginez votre réponse nicolas sarkozy
nous ne sommes pas d'accord sur les
chiffres est là encore les observateurs
seront litière de tout cela
le flux migratoire annuel atteint son
maximum historique la dernière année du
gouvernement de lionel jospin avec 215
milles titre de séjour 215 mais
qui faisait suite à une régularisation
générale de 80000 personnes en situation
illégale
le flux migratoires annuels aujourd'hui
280 milles je conteste donc formelle de
ressembler en moyenne sur les dix
dernières années monsieur hollande les
observateurs for all a aussi une fille
hollande c'est walt à 180 m la france
est un pays ouvert
et je sais moi même d'où je viens le
problème est le suivant
nous avons accueilli trop de monde ce
qui a paralysé notre système
d'intégration
nous n'avons pas assez d'emplois pas
assez d'écoles pas assez de logements il
faut donc réduire le nombre de ceux que
nous accueillons pas parce que nous les
aimons pas pas parce que nous en avons
peur mais parce qu'on n'arrive plus à
les intégrer deuxième élément je ne peux
pas dire aux français il faut faire des
économies réduire nos dépenses et
accepter l'immigration qui viendraient
en france que parce qu'elle est hanté
par des prestations sociales parmi les
plus généreuses j'ai donc proposé sur
les cinq années qui viennent de faire en
sorte que nous division par 2 le flux
migratoire entrant en france 189 90 me
comment allons nous y arriver première
proposition
un juge unique pour le droit des
étrangers aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le
même juge qui maintient étrangers en
france c'est ça la rendra avec
l'immigration légale ça ces projets en
région c'est pour l'exclusion la mesure
allait une autre chose non si pour
l'immigration légale scénario la voie
non c'est pas le juge qui décide
aujourd'hui
quelqu'un qui arrive en france on le met
en rétention pour voir si correspond un
critère de régularisation
à 6 rapprochement familial il est en
rétention le juge de la rétention c'est
le juge judiciaire et le juge de
l'expulsion c'est le juge administratif
je souhaite que ce soit le même juge
parce que si on libère de la rétention
quelqu'un avant lui avoir donné une
réponse vous avez le droit d'entrée pas
le droit d'entrer s'il est rentré avant
naturellement ne pourra pas l'expulser
après ça sera beaucoup plus difficile
deuxième élément je propose que pour
tout nouvel entrant y compris sur le
rapprochement familial comme sur le
regroupement familial parce que les deux
c'est 65 mille personnes par an je
propose que dans tous nos consulats soit
organiser un examen de français avant
l'entrée sur le territoire pour toute
personne ayant un âge qui dépasse 16 ans
et de connaissance des valeurs de la
république car je ne sais pas comment on
peut intégrer en france des personnes
qui ne parle pas un mot de français et
enfin pour éviter qu'on devienne en
france que pour la traite certaines
prestations sociales je propose qu'on ne
puisse toucher des prestations sociales
comme le minimum vieillesse ou le rsa
qu'après dix années de présence en
france et 5 années de cotisation après
tout que les étrangers en france aient
les mêmes droits et les mêmes devoirs
que lui s'il ya un autre sujet qui vous
divise c'est le droit de vote pour les
immigrés non membres de la communauté
européenne aux élections municipales
vous y êtes favorables françois hollande
d'avoir un mot sur ce qui vient d'être
dit la question du juge n'a rien à voir
avec l'immigration légale questions du
juge c'est par rapport à l'immigration
illégale pour favoriser ou faciliter
l'expulsion donc la proposition de
monsieur sarkozy n'est pas du tout
approprié à l'immigration légale elle
est approprié à lima la lutte contre
l'immigration illégale par ailleurs que
je peux comprendre mais qui doit d'abord
touché les filières clandestines mais
j'arrive à votre question combien je le
droit de rétention et bien sûr que les
gars sur les droits alors pour les trois
années écrit dans cette lettre dans
cette lettre reuteurs général de france
terre d'asile je cite je souhaite me
françois hollande que la rétention
devienne l'exception
je m'explique ya plus de rétention de
journée on peut là il s'agit et les
mails agit là il s'agit de lyme création
irrégulière irrégulière pas légal
irrégulière pour les centres de
rétention on met pas des personnes qui
sont entrés illégalement sur notre
territoire bien sûr non donc est ce bien
la jeunesse sur le centre de mes temps
sera plus un problème d'immigration
illégale et là vous avez parlé nous
parlions des migrations puissent vous
réservant sur l'orientation des gens sur
vous n'étiez pas du tout allait se
rendre et ans sur l'ordre du jour
n'était pas du tout dans le sud et
centre de rétention mais sur les centres
de rétention a voulu changer de sujet
sur le centre de rétention moi je
considère que un enfant ne peut pas être
mis dans un centre de rétention
parce que il est avec sa famille au
milieu d'autres étrangers dans des
conditions très difficiles conditions de
rétention et donc ce que nos yeux jospin
ce que nous devons le juriste qui est
bien ce que nous devons faire maintenant
c'est d'avoir des centres de rétention
permettant l'accueil des familles pour
permettre en syrie exige le relais du
fonds d'1 seul sait si cela alors je
viens la région du droit font qu'on
garde les centres de rétention ils sont
de rétention sont nécessaires existent
partout donc pourquoi ils river vous le
contraire à france terre des traces que
toujours l'ambiguïté normes et capa
aucune ambiguïté lorsque la personne
doit et est menacée la réponse immune à
venir la session nous me souvenir
français mais ne regarderais non je dis
que je garderai les centres de rétention
et que la personne qui risquent de
s'enfuir doit être mis en centre de
rétention je n'ai rien au droit
brésilien arrive au droit de vote cette
lettre vous l'avais envoyé et je n'ai
envoyé mais bien je venais de vous
contredire mais pas du tout sur un sujet
aussi important que l'existant un centre
de rétention c'est à dire là où vont
tous les étrangers qui n'ont pas encore
de papier on examine la situation
monsieur hollande écrit à transfère
d'asile la rétention doit devenir
l'exception et vous venez bien quand
c'est leur sérieux mais sur un sujet
lorsque vous savez que vous savez que
beaucoup d'étrangers qui sont reconduits
ne passe pas au centre de rétention bon
comment les retrouver des conditions de
reddition temps assigné à résidence et
ensuite ils sont un signe oui absolument
dont et donc est ensuite reconduit à la
frontale ce qu'un étranger qui arrive en
situation et là il s'agit pas de nos
jeunes il s'agit il a une résidence
l'avion un saab et il arrive souvent que
ces étrangers là soit en france depuis
ushuaia
bien que le droit ne seraient pas des
étrangers qui sont arrivés depuis
quelques le droit de voir ses droits le
voyez bien après cette digression sur le
droit de vote
c'est une position que je défends depuis
des années
uniquement pour les élections
municipales et par rapport à des
étrangers en situation régulière sur le
territoire est installé depuis plus de
cinq ans monsieur sarkozy vous étiez
favorable à cette position vous l'aviez
écrit en 2001 rappelé en 2005 confirmé
en 2008 vous disiez vous étiez
intellectuellement favorable à cette
introduction du droit de vote des
étrangers pour les élections municipales
mais que vous n'aviez pas la majorité
vous avez parfaitement le droit de
changer moi je ne change pas je
considère donc que ces personnes qui
sont sur notre territoire depuis
longtemps qui payent des impôts locaux
doivent pouvoir participer au scrutin
municipal et ça existe un lien dans la
plupart des pays européens
et notamment en belgique aux pays-bas
royaume-uni pour les membres du
commonwealth et en espagne sous réserve
de réciprocité je pourrais continuer ya
à peu près 50 pays dans le monde
beaucoup sont en europe qui appliquent
le droit de vote des étrangers pour les
élections municipales pour faire passer
cette réforme il nous faudra avoir une
majorité des trois cinquièmes c'est un
une révision de la constitution
je soumettrai donc cette proposition au
parlement
s'il y a une majorité des trois
cinquièmes eh bien ça voudra dire qu'une
partie de la droite et du centre et vous
avez beaucoup de vos amis par un certain
nombre qui sont favorables et la réforme
passera s'il n'y a pas de majorité eh
bien ça sera au peuple français et
seulement au peuple français de pouvoir
en décider c'est sa reconnaissance de
notre bilan j'ai beaucoup réfléchi sur
cette question qui est une question
difficile et sur lesquelles il faut
compter sur lesquels il faut prendre des
engagements clairs qu'est ce qui s'est
passé depuis dix ans on a une montée des
tensions communautaires extravagantes on
a une radicalisation
et une pression disons les choses comme
elles sont d'un islam de france alors
que nous voulons un islam en france
je considère comme irresponsable de
proposer un vote communautariste et à
votre communautaire alors que nous
sommes face à des tensions
communautaires et identitaire est
extraordinairement forte monsieur
hollande dit c'est pas grave ce sont les
élections municipales il a tort parce
que l'élection municipale et le maire
c'est la deuxième élection est le
deuxième personnage avant après le
président république les élections il ya
plus de participation c'est l'élection
présidentielle élections municipales il
a une deuxième fois tort parce que les
élus locaux que vous élisez certes à
élire les lits flatteur puisque en
france quand on est un conseil municipal
c'est le conseil municipal qui est libre
vous avez ces gens je vous arrête là
dessus cette règle existe déjà pour les
résidents communautaire pour les
résidents européens et vous savez que
les conseillers municipaux
européens
ne peuvent pas voter pour les élections
sénatoriales donc ce que vous avez dit
est faux il ya une grande différence
entre nous n'aurons pas plus de
conseillers municipaux
étrangers que nous n'aurons de
conseillers municipaux européens et ils
ont exactement les mêmes droits et en
l'occurrence ils n'auront pas le droit
d'y participer à l'élection du sénat par
yom permettez moi de vous dire si je je
peux juste faire cette interruption
pourra vous laisser supposer que les
étrangers non communautaires
sont des fans européens sont des
musulmans pourquoi vous dites ça qu'est
ce qui vous permet de dire que ceux qui
ne sont pas européens sont musulmans
si je peux terminer mon rêver excusez
moi à ma question merci je vais terminer
mon réseau oui mais vous répondrai tout
à l'heure à cette occasion j'imagine
mais bien sûr je termine je répondrai à
cette question d'abord parce que la
différence entre un étranger
communautaire comme l'on dit pas ce
commentaire citoyenneté européenne
il ya un projet politique européen et ya
monsieur hollande la réciprocité en
europe les français dans d'autres pays
vote et les européens en france votent
pas de problème
et vous savez très bien que le droit de
vote pour les immigrés il s'adresse à
qui ils s'adressent pas aux canadiens il
s'adresse pas aux américains il
s'adresse pour l'essentiel à ce qu'est
la réalité de l'immigration française
qui est une émigration
africaines afrique du nord afrique
subsaharienne si vous ne savez pas ça
mais si vous ne vous en faites une
minute un lien avec une charnière
religieuse puis je termine et il en fait
un lien avec l'appui solide si je peux
terminer à les contester que le droit de
vote aux immigrés c'est un droit de vote
qui rend d'abord à une communauté
d'afrique du nord où une communauté
succès aérienne c'est ne rien connaître
un bel migratoire est ce que vous êtes
atteint 12 en fait parfait conséquence à
givet j'ai une religion attendez j'ai
donc on est bien d'accord que là
l'essentiel de lait des personnes
concernées ne seront pas les norvégiens
ne seront pas nous avons marqué nous ne
serons pas les agneaux assez étrange est
la même et non parce que la première
communauté les premières économies alors
quelles conséquences du chantier
les premières communautés étrangères en
france sont algériennes sont tunisiennes
sont marocaines sont malienne elles ne
sont pas de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
c'est une réalité que de dire ça les
pans de faire un procès à leur décrit
une réalité alors continué deuxièmement
si vous prenez les pays d'afrique du
nord
ce sont des pays de confession musulmane
oui ou non ça veut dépenser c'est pas
quelque chose je vous apprends vous
pensez donc si je veux terminer les
écrans pas quand même ça que c'est de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée que
l'algérie ces musulmans que le maroc
s'est pour l'essentiel de religion une
confession musulmane le roi étant même
le commandeur des croyants et que la
tunisie c'est pareil les tensions
communautaires dont je parle elles
viennent de qui viennent d'eau le
problème que nous avons à gérer
extrêmement difficile pour la république
sauf à ce que vous et un masque devant
les yeux et que vous ignorez totalement
la réalité dans nos quartiers ils
viennent de quoi de l'absolue nécessité
d'avoir un islam de france et non pas
d'un islam en france c'est bien là que
se trouve le problème il se trouve pas
ailleurs refusé de le considérer s'y
refuser de voir la réalité si vous
donner le droit de vote aux immigrés
avec la tentation communautariste que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui et que nous
voyons chaque jour que vous dénoncez
comme moi d'ailleurs à ce moment là pour
les municipales y aura des revendication
identitaire et communautaire des
horaires différentielle pour les femmes
et les hommes dans les pistes des menus
différencier dans les cantines
municipales des médecins différencié
pour les hommes et les femmes dans
l'hôpital mais ce que vous y
trompez pas non mais ça répond ce type 2
non mes excuses et de déclarations n'ont
alors terminé nicolas matérialiser mais
c'est moi qui ai créé le cfcm et je
n'accepterai aucune leçon la matière
mais dire que le problème communautaire
aujourd'hui que le problème
d'intégration aujourd'hui se pose
d'abord pour l'immigration venant
d'afrique du nord et d'afrique
subsaharienne que c'est un problème pour
nous que l'islam de france est devenue
la deuxième religion de france que nous
avons fait un effort considérable pour
qu'ils aient des deux lieux de culte
puisqu'il ya 2200 mosquée par parenthèse
la france traite mieux les musulmans en
france que les chrétiens ne sont
traitées en orient alors que c'est un
problème la red rose arnaud françois
hollande et que nous devons imaginer
pour qu'il n'y ait pas d'amalgamé que
chacun soit traité à égalité de droits
et de devoirs
une intégration et un islam de france
c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu la loi
interdisant la burqa parce que la burqa
sur le territoire de la république n'a
pas sa place parce que vous ne l'avez
pas dotés d'ailleurs cette loi on se
demande bien pourquoi m vous n'avez pas
voté réponse est absent ce jour-là
répond parti socialiste courageusement a
pris la poudre d'escampette
quand il a fallu voter j'ai analysé
réponse aux landais on parle du
nucléaire d'abord sur le droit de vote
vous y étiez favorable en 2008 ses pas
il ya moins de tensions de réciprocité
un très long temps oui ou non c'est pas
vrai dans leurs tiges et que vous avez
fait dans le parisien c'était sans
conditionnel choisi d intellectuellement
favorable je rappelle d'ailleurs que je
la paye cash les trolls pas un pays
comme le maroc accorde la réciprocité
pour le droit de vote aux élections
locales
donc même avec sept réserves soit le
changement votre argument de jeunes à
grandir donc allez-y françois hollande
vous aviez pris cette position vous
étiez déjà précieux nabeul et vous en
changez vous avez le droit deuxièmement
vous dites ça va introduire des
revendications communautaires
je mets en cause ce principe parce que
il ya des étrangers qui sont là depuis
des années qui viennent effectivement
d'afrique ou du maghreb qui peuvent être
musulman ou pas musulman pratiquants ou
pas pratiquants et qui ne conçoivent pas
forcément une participation à une
élection locale comme un instrument de
pression religieuse je vous fais
d'ailleurs observé qu'il y à des
français qui sont de culte musulman
aujourd'hui est ce que ces français là
font des pressions communautaires sont
français ils votent comme des citoyens
français ce qu'ils font des pressions
communautaires pour que nous mangions
une certaine viande ou pour que nous
ayons des horaires par des centaines de
mines et étrangers entrant là il y à des
musulmans en france
citoyen français qui ne font pas de
revendications communautaires à ce que
je sache donc pourquoi il y aurait à
l'occasion des élections municipales
pour des étrangers qui sont là depuis
des années tu ne joues pas nécessaire
des jeunes en 5 ans bailey et
quelquefois cinq ans souvent sur les
parents et vous le savez très bien cinq
ans sur les parents de citoyens français
combien avons-nous de cas et vous les
connaissez ou des français qui sont nés
en france qui sont devenus donc citoyens
ont leurs propres parents qui sont venus
en france il ya trente ans il ya 40 ans
il ya cinquante ans et qui sont restés
mais c'est lent et on sent exceptée
celle finalement leur doivent devenir
les français risque mais nous pensions
le temps tu n'as donc que les immigrés
en france puisse bosser jure voilà on
sait les positions c'est une fausse idée
nous pouvons ne pas être d'accord
meslier liés comme vous l'avez fait le
le vote à une jolie ration communautés
régions est et je dedans que les
français n'aient aucune inquiétude
réside en australie sous la présidence
il n'y aura aucune dérogation à quelques
règles que ce soit en matière de laïcité
j'avais j'ai rencontré divergent
cependant les noms c'est pourquoi je
tiens à vous par exemple l'internet
n'est pas favorable aux eaux à la loi
sur le voile à l'école vous n'étiez pas
fera nous avions fait un débat ensemble
c'était au théâtre du rond point en 2003
et j'ai encore le texte vous disiez que
vous n'étiez pas favorable à
l'interdiction du voile à l'école
c'était votre droit à l'époque savent
sans doute encore changer d'avis moi
j'étais favorable et je vais voter cette
loi en introduction de l'interdiction du
voile à l'école c'était jacques chirac
qui en avait décidé vous n'étiez pas
favorable ensuite sur la burqa j'ai voté
la résolution
interdisant la burqa et ensuite il y à
une avait voté la résolution vous avez
voté la loi la région et l'annoncé d'un
nouveau titre sur la loi j'avais avec le
groupe socialiste déposer des
amendements qui n'ont pas été reçus la
meilleure des façons et est donc de
laisser passer la loi mais je vous
l'affirmé ici la loi sur la burqa si je
deviens président de la république sera
strictement appliquée il n'y aura pas
non plus ce que vous faites souvent ce
type de proclamation dans vos réunions
publiques je vous entendre indirectement
les horaires de piscine il n'y a aucun
horaires de piscine qui sera tolérée
s'il fait la distinction entre les
hommes et les femmes plusieurs
municipalités ont fait vous avez souvent
cité martine aubry s'est terminée depuis
2009 c'était pour des femmes qui étaient
en surpoids qui en avait fait la demande
je rappelle que noyade un bovin surnommé
plus haut que aucun horaire
il yad'autres municipal y ait de droit
mon surpoids il ya d'autres
municipalités de droite concerne aux
légalistes j'ai refusé j'ai refusé qu'il
y ait la moindre ouverture et si vous
voulez constater qu'il n'ya plus
d'ouverture d'horreur spécifiques pour
les femmes je vous donnerai le site de
la mairie de lille pour que vous
puissiez aller à la piscine ou le débat
questions deuxièmement nous avions dans
l'instant sur la viande halal que les
français sachent bien que sous ma
présidence rien ne sera tolérée en
termes de présence de viande halal dans
les cantines de nos écoles donc il n'y
est pas il ne résidait de faire peur et
quand ça au vote de la loi subisse vieux
rock en vitrine énorme et je les assume
parfaitement et sur la loi sur le droit
de vote des étrangers qui suppose une
modification de la constitution soit il
ya une majorité des 3 5e ce qui
supposera qu'une partie de la droite et
du centre votent cette fois soit les
français seront consultés et si vous
voulez je vais terminer là dessus
monsieur sarkozy lui faut vraiment qu'on
avance s'il vous plaît j'essaie d'avoir
une cohérence dans les convictions je ne
change pas en fonction des circonstances
ou des votes qui peuvent intervenir au
premier tour d'une élection
présidentielle
je préfère tenir bon sur une position
que je défends depuis des années plutôt
que d'en changer sous la pression des
circonstances
monsieur monsieur landes je sais que
j'ai une chance de l'humour mais vous
tenir bon sur vos convictions c'est
franchement pas vous et passât sur le
centre de rétention je note que vous
allez les gardez vous avez premier en
france des rallyes de les supprimer non
sur la régularisation vous aviez promis
de les faire on n'a toujours pas compris
quelle sera votre politique vous n'avez
aucun objectif chiffré en termes
d'immigration sauf sur l'immigration
économique qui représente 15 mille cas
si je 180000 l'adieu le droit de vote
mais là-dessus journée nicolas sarkozy
de répondre aux situations sarkozy qui
se dit que nous resterons sur 180 milles
sur le nombre de régularisations ça
restera autour de tremper
puisqu'actuellement vous régularisez
dans trois mois je suis chaque année je
dis qu'il faut qu'ils nous avons fait la
différence vos jeux des savants cboe
début 90 milles jeudi 180 et enfin sur
la burqa vous avez voté la résolution 8
pas voter la loi mais vous changerez pas
la loi si vous n'êtes pas quelqu'un qui
varient comme la gironde où vous avez
pas changé sur les droits de vote et
richement vers la sortie tout droit de
vote des étrangers vous dire oui
pourquoi alors voilà parce que mais je
vous l'expliqué et vous monsieur le
voile à l'école monsieur vous avez
chargé ce n'est pas exact appartenait au
gouvernement qui a fait don il avait
examiné mercredi permettez moi de vous
dire j'appartenais au gouvernement qui a
fait sur télé vous avez expérience est
une illusion et comme le disait monsieur
votre ami monsieur chevènement un
ministre s'applique la politique du
gouvernement donc gelé parfaitement
accepté je vous dire simplement que
quand il a fallu avoir du courage pour
interdire la burqa sur le territoire la
république française vous étiez aux
abonnés en sorte que deux là vont voter
la résolution
n'a aucun dans la résolution vous avez
voté un principe virtuel pamiers
voudrait été incapable d'assumer une
interdiction qui est aujourd'hui en
cause parce que chez nous dans la
république française les personnes
femmes ne les rassure et personne ne
peut le dire une précision et sachant
pas tolérer tous masculins ce jour là
vous n'avez même pas le courage de voter
non vous êtes abstenu et participer je
le dis parce que il ya des
désabonnements que vous n'avez pas
accepter non dans ce cas là il fallait
voter donc alors je ne voudrais pas nous
excuser parce que vous ne trouvez pas
votre ennemi ou non par rapport à une
loi qui devait passer avait ri public
health et remettait à ce qu' aucune
femme depuis cette rentrée renaissent si
derrière un voile aviez peur me dorion
janvier peur de l'incapacité pour la
république de faire respecter cette loi
or cette loi a été appliquée elle est
respectée et il n'y a pas de burqa ou de
voile intégral sur le toit de la glace
il y en a encore quelque chose qu'on
peut et abonnés d'autres tels que 300
cas
d'application clair non ça y est ça y
est qu'ils ont retrouvé la liberté voilà
nécessairement mais en tout cas de ce
débat on passe au nucléaire laurence
allons-y effectivement quelle est votre
philosophie en termes de nucléaire on va
peut-être poser la question nicolas
sarkozy qui en en retard sur le temps de
parole non seulement je dirais en termes
d'exploitation de centrales mais aussi
en termes de solutions d'avenir pour les
énergies écoutez le nucléaire depuis
général de gaulle françois mitterrand
valéry giscard d'estaing jacques chirac
ça fait l'objet d'un consensus
c'est un atout france il ya 58 réacteurs
nous avons une électricité moins chère
de 35% que nos partenaires allemands 30
des 58 réacteurs ont été ouverts sous la
présidence de françois mitterrand
personne n'a jamais remis en cause cela
c'est 240 mille emplois c'est un
avantage considérable pour notre
industrie et pour nos compatriotes qui
se chauffent à l'électricité ou qui ont
besoin de l'électricité d'où vient le
problème le problème vient de la
négociation entre les socialistes et les
verts qui voient rouge dès qu'on leur
parle de nucléaire et l'a fallu leur
donner des gages monsieur hollande
propose de revenir de 75 à 50% de la
production nucléaire c'est à dire de
fermer 24 réacteurs nucléaires par un
tour de magie ces 24 c'est tombé sur ces
malheureux de fessenheim on se demande
pourquoi la centrale de fessenheim à une
trentaine d'années où une quarantaine
d'années et vient d'être contrôlé parle
l'asn qui est l'autorité de sécurité
nucléaire qui est totalement
indépendante et qui fait référence dans
le monde entier pourquoi sacrifier le
nucléaire pour un accord politique
misérable car il n'y a aucune raison de
fermer le nucléaire en france depuis
tenue et claires existent nous n'avons
jamais connu un accident grave
quand il ya eu la sphère de fukushima
nous avons décidé d'auditer la totalité
de nos centrales pour voir quelles
conclusions nous devions tirer de cela
mettre à bas le nucléaire parce que
madame joly fait 2,5 pour cent des voix
c'est un choix gravissime nous n'avons
pas de pétrole nous n'avons pas de gaz
nous avons le nucléaire enfin le
nucléaire ne nous empêche pas de
développer les économies les énergies
renouvelables depuis que je suis
président de la république nous sommes
passés de 10 % et demie d'énergies
renouvelables de notre pack énergétique
à 13 nous avons multiplié par 4 notre
puissance éolienne et tenez vous bien
nous avons multiplié par 100 notre
puissance voltec il nous faut le
nucléaire et il nous faut le
renouvelable les deux ensemble parce que
nous n'avons pas pétrole parce que nous
n'avons pas de gaz et parce que nous
n'avons pas d'énergie pour réponse de
françois hollande nous avons en france
une double dépendance une dépendance à
l'égard du pétrole nous avons parlé et
une dépendance à l'égard du nucléaire
qui se situe à un niveau très élevé ça
nous a longtemps protégé ça va 75% de
source nucléaire pour la production
d'électricité
le deuxième pays derrière nous c'est
l'ukraine
et ensuite des pays comme le japon qui
sont à 30% ou qui était à 30% après que
se soient produits la catastrophe de
fukushima qui quand même à marquer un
certain nombre d'esprits vous avez dit
que vous étiez allé vous n'étiez jamais
allé mais enfin qu'importe ça quand même
porté sur les esprits de nos concitoyens
un certain nombre de conséquences j'ai
donc considéré que nous devions avoir un
objectif de long terme c'est à dire
garder le nucléaire comme source
principale de production de
l'électricité
mais réduire sa part à mesure que les
énergies renouvelables allait être
stimulés et relevé 50 % de production
d'électricité de source nucléaire à
l'horizon 2025 nous sommes à 75 %
et donc je ferai l'effort pour que les
énergies renouvelables soient
considérablement développé vous dites
que vous avez favorisé le nu le solaire
c'est faux puisqu'il ya eu l'arrêt de
tout ce qui était incitation ou
photovoltaïque et notamment les prix de
rachat ça a déstructuré complètement
cette industrie et nous avons perdu de
nombreux emplois il faut savoir que
l'allemagne à 230 mille emplois dans les
énergies renouvelables nous seulement 58
donc il y aura une réduction de la part
du nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité
quelle sera la conséquence sur le
prochain quinquennat moi je ne suis
candidat que pour les cinq prochaines
années une seule centrale fermera une
fête selon m on me dit mais pourquoi
fait cela mais on me dit souvent vous
fait certain nombre de plaisanterie là
dessus par rapport à fukushima une
centrale c'est la plus vieille de france
elle se trouve en plus sur une zone
sismique à côté du canal d'alsace tout
autour les mobilisations sont très
fortes pour sa fermeture je comprends
parfaitement la position des
travailleurs de fessenheim qui veulent
garder cette centrale tous les emplois
seront préservés puisqu'il y aura une
réutilisation de tous ces travailleurs
par rapport à d'autres activités qui
leur seront proposées sur place et
notamment l'institut de démantèlement
des centrales nucléaires parce qu'il ya
400 centrales qui va falloir fermer à
l'échelle du monde et nous devons être
les meilleurs dans cette activité je lis
une motion qui a été fait pour la
fermeture de fessenheim du groupe ump
nouveau centre du conseil municipal de
strasbourg et y en a plein comme ça donc
c'est pas un problème simplement
gauche-droite votre propre porte parole
de campagne puisque vous avez cité le
mien madame kosciusko morizet disait que
c'était possible de fermer fessenheim
que c'était d'ailleurs prévu mais qu'
elle n'avait pas pu en décider le
gouvernement
alors la réponse peut donc alain colas à
ce que je dis une seule centrale fermera
durant le prochain quinquennat une et
que par ailleurs je ne suis pas lié sur
cette question avec le les verts puisque
sur cette partie du nucléaire dans
l'accord qui avait été passé je ne l'est
pas reconnu en revanche c'est pas michel
sapin qui la cie nommé vous non c'est
pas michel sapin qui la tire c'est
martine aubry qui a signé ce point et
j'ai dit que dans mon projet
présidentiel je ne retiendrai qu'une
seule centrale pour le prochain
quinquennat alors est-ce que ce que je
ne comprends pas soit le nucléaire c'est
dangereux soit c'est pas dangereux si le
nucléaire est dangereux il faut fermer
il faut pas simplement fermer fessenheim
parce que fessenheim avec trente ans
d'âge figurez vous et plus sûr que quand
fessenheim est inauguré pourquoi parce
que l'autorité indépendante
dès qu'il y à un accident partout dans
le monde applique la règle de précaution
tire les conséquences de cet accident où
que ce soit dans le monde pour augmenter
la sécurité donc je comprends pas pour
vous y accueille son âne qui est
dangereux il se trouve que l'asn vient
de terminer l'examen décennale et
post-fukushima du réacteur numéro un de
fessenheim qu'est ce que dit l'autorité
indépendante qui s'imposent à nous elle
dit fessenheim ne pose aucun problème
voilà les travaux qu'il faut faire c'est
cela il peut continuer pourquoi voulez
vous la fermer pour faire plaisir à
madame joly je la ferme à ce jeu là
c'est vrai à la seule qui arrive est
l'ambassadeur de la faille a demandé
là-dessus particulièrement je vais la
mettre hors de cause je vous l'affirmé
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
c'est la plus ancienne centrale qu'une
centrale était prévu dans l'ombre pour
30 ans et elle aura 40 ans d'âge en 2017
que deuxièmement elle est proche d'une
zone sismique ce qui est quand même un
risque par ailleurs je vais ajouter un
autre argument nous sommes obligés de
faire des travaux sur les vieilles
centrales et à mesure que l sont
prolongées il faut faire des
investissements et donc le choix qui va
se faire pour les prochaines années et
qui engagera toute la collectivité
nationale c est ce que nous faisons des
travaux sur l'église centrale pour les
prolonger ou est ce que nous
investissons davantage pour les énergies
renouvelables et c'est le rôle d'areva
c'est le rôle d'edf vous avez affaiblit
considérablement areva et donc il nous
faudra remettre un certain nombre de
moyens dans areva pour que nous ayons à
la fois du nucléaire ou plus sûr encore
parce que nous devons donner cette
garantie et des énergies renouvelables
rêve réponse de nicolas sachy jamais on
arrête les centrales nucléaires en
suisse qui ne sont pas prévus pour être
des gens tellement qu'ils aiment le
risque ont 60 ans donc le problème n'est
pas l'âge c'est l'autorité de sécurité
qui doit dire si on peut continuer ou si
on ne peut pas aimer uniquement qu'on
peut continuer avec des investissements
de plus en plus d'importance et sac elle
dit deuxièmement fermer fessenheim c'est
8000 éoliennes en alsace pour remplacer
fessenheim il nous faut pas le nucléaire
ou le renouvelable il nous faut le
nucléaire nous aurons et le renouveler
aux rond pendant moi il y en a et le
nucléaire et le renouvelable puisqu'il
n'y aura qu'une centrale qui fermera par
ailleurs vous savez que j'ai accepté et
c'était la paix sic et c'était pas
facile j'ai accepté de prolonger le
chantier de le p r chantier comme
extrêmement lourd qui a connu un certain
nombre de visites du mais j'ai considéré
parce que je suis attachée au progrès
technologique que ce nouveau réacteur de
troisième génération de vous avez une
avance françois hollande nicolas sarkozy
jamais justine géant tourner la page
vous inventez la règle des 30 ans
professionnel quelle est l'histoire que
nous avons des 40 ans parce que ses 40
ans quelle est l'histoire que nous avons
vu il y avait aucun problème entre la
gauche et la droite ça faisait consensus
sur le nucléaire tout d'un coup il ya un
problème pourquoi pas ce que vous
imaginiez la nécessité d'un accord
politique c'est pas trop le faire parce
qu'il savait vendu pas ce qui s'est
passé à fukushima zone pas et parce que
les énergies renouvelables doivent être
développées trou sable et quand je n'ai
rien vendu du jour ça fait le genre que
celle que pas ce vocabulaire vous avez
vendu les ouvriers de fessenheim le
gagnant sur l'autel d'un accord mais
prison puisque cette agonie titien ce
que cet accord n'est pas celui que j'ai
moi même intégré dans n'ont pas bien
donc c'est pas plus et pas 3 et jean
castelain c'est pas pour ça ne nous
engage pas donc de laisser sa pensée
depuis la jeune âge pas quelques
concessions que ce soit à une
organisation ivory depuis que je suis
président de la république j'avais pris
l'engagement un euro dans le nucléaire
un euro dans le renouvelable ça n'a pas
aidé mais enfin c'est exactement ce qui
a été fait la puissance voltaïque x 100
mais enfin vous considérez quand même
que la cinquième puissance du monde va
pas fonctionner uniquement avec le
photovoltaïque
et l'éolien et je dis ça prenait je dis
ça parce que je m'exerce tandis que j'ai
pris et à 50% longue de caricaturer pas
les positions c'est pas la peine mais
monsieur hollande vous ramenez le
nucléaire de 75 à 50 pour 2025 vous le
réduit ses mais oui mais quand un
président de la république prend une
décision ça s'impose aux autres qui le
suivent il faut au contraire le
développer vous imaginez c'est ce que je
vais l'engagement que je prends
au nom de la france d'avoir dans le pack
énergétique français 23% d'énergies
renouvelables en 2020 c'est un
engagement considérable la vérité elle
est là elle vous gêne le nucléaire ne
pose aucun problème de sécurité en
france entre les honneurs binaire il
faudra se tourner vers le plus sûr du
monde reconnu comme tel à fukushima ça
n'a pas été un problème nucléaire
c'était un problème de tsunami qui a
cassé les pompes de refroidissement
la centrale qui est pourtant une vieille
centrale à fukushima le moteur c'est
parfaitement arrêté c'est un problème de
tsunami et je ne pense pas qu aux
frontières du rhin est un problème de
tsunami en vérité si les coraux ce n'est
pas pour le sien s'il vous plaît france
par l'om une zone sismique bien sûr j'ai
quelques années mais bien sûr ce n'est
pas que si vous les élus autour se
blesser on a compris aux diverses
sarkozy quand j'en attends pris leur
argent ça vous caméra donc dans ce cas
la chose et non le tout est clair vous
avez droit à la version pour la sortie
du nucléaire seulement sur moi je suis
pour une position équilibrée parce que
l'ambiance est la plus intelligente elle
vous allez en bas rhin par là dessus en
jeu la femme ose y termine dans ce cas
là il faut fermer toutes les semaines je
vous dis que vaut mieux une position est
ce que jean teulère vision dogmatique
toutes les centrales nucléaires qui se
trouve près d'une zone sismique puisque
toutes nos centrales nucléaires sont
construites avec des normes de sécurité
it pour résister si tu es moins d'eau
qui râlent cgt - en central du match
monsieur monsieur connaît pas de
monsieur monsieur je ne connais pas
violent quant à le p r c'est moi qui
l'ait signé mais l'énergie nucléaire
plus nous travaillons et nous
investissons plus elle est solide stable
et sûr ce sera justement là-dessus quel
message envoyé à l'industrie nucléaire
dans le monde il ya 300 projets de
construction de centrales en ce moment
et que te dire que monsieur hollande dit
ma première décision ça sera de fermer
une centrale la plus vieille laurence on
enseigne ma décision est ferme et la
plus vieille centrale et de continuer la
plus modeste mais sur la meilleure des
situations et son bord t on à condé
nouvelles cendres eux n'en parlait plus
vivante non c'est le panneau une asso
technologiques dont il arrive aussi que
vous laissez pas on a compris vos
diverses voir dans la situation où je
serais moi compris vos divers l'emprunt
de de défendre une industrie on enchaîne
sur la vie politique ça vous intéresse
aussi jb ça vous intéresse aussi
nucléaire donc pour laquelle j'ai grande
confiance mais qui doit être portée sur
les réacteurs de nouvelle génération et
pas sur les vieilles centrales n'ont
alors je dois vous laisser les clés
lacie lance alors un nom mais c'est
extrêmement important d'entamer par là
il ya une autorité indépendante de
sûreté nucléaire il me semble que le
devoir de président de la république
c'est d'écouter ce que c'est les jeux
les traités et inaki valoir faire des
travailleurs wallon rendant le juge
central motivations de la vie j'ai
publié mon enterrement
l'autorité s'est prononcé sur toutes les
centrales avec l'indonésie se monterait
à temps à la demande du gouvernement
c'est une folie de fermer une centrale
de 30 ans d'âge alors qu'elle peut
compter dans à bien entendre parler d'un
sanandaj vienne ou d'en rire mais nous
ne sommes pas dans korité vous voulez
bien une centrale on a changé de
l'ancienne chanteuse on accomplit ce
désaccord la vie politique et ses règles
à un petit point sur les temps de parole
nicolas sarkozy vous avez 57 minutes et
12 secondes de temps de parole monsieur
long de 58 minutes et 43 secondes on va
maintenant aborder le troisième grand
chapitre de ce débat quelle présidente
pour le quinquennat qui s'annonce
comment comptez vous présidez l'un et
l'autre quel style de président conté
vous être mais aussi quelle marge de
manoeuvre aurait vous quel levier
pourrait vous actionnez nicolas sarkozy
vous prétendez un second quinquennat
allez vous présidez différemment pour
moi je crois que le président de la
république c'est quelqu'un qui assume
ses responsabilités qui doit être
profondément engagé qui n'a pas le droit
de dire qu'il ne peut pas qu'il ne veut
pas qu'il aurait voulu mais qui n'a pas
pu qui doit être en première ligne
qui doit conduire un certain nombre de
changements extraordinairement difficile
dans un monde lui même
extraordinairement complexe dans les
cinq années qui viennent je vous
proposer aux français un nouveau modèle
français de croissance un nouveau modèle
français basé sur l'économie du savoir
la formation professionnelle des
changements à l'école pour que notre
école de la république sur une école de
l'exigence je pense qu'un président de
la république ne peut pas dire comme le
disait devant le désastre de vilvorde
monsieur jospin on n'y peut rien je
pense qu'un président la république peut
pas dire comme le disait françois
mitterrand dans une émission restée
célèbre sur le chômage on a tout essayé
on n'y peut rien je pense qu'un
président de la république c'est
quelqu'un surtout avec le quinquennat
qui assume ses responsabilités qui prend
des décisions
qui ait mûri par l'expérience des crises
qu'il a eues affronter c'est sans doute
la fonction la plus difficile qui soit
une fonction que j'ai appris pendant
cinq ans à laquelle j'ai tout donné de
mon énergie de mon expérience où je n'ai
pas tout réussi et cette expérience j'ai
considéré qu'au moment historique que
vit la france un moment où le monde
bouge à une vitesse stupéfiante ya un
monde nouveau qui est en train d'arriver
alors que le monde ancien pantin par est
entre n'a pas encore disparu je pense
qu'on ne peut pas s'en remettre aux
vieilles lunes du passé je pense qu'on
ne peut pas être à contre-courant dû
monde qu'il faut s'inscrire dans le
monde peser sur le monde essayait
d'avoir les idées claires et porter un
projet de très fortes ambitions france à
roland qu'elle préside en compte et vous
être
un président qui d'abord respecte les
français qui les considèrent
un président qui ne veut pas être
président de tout chef de tout et en
définitive responsable de rien moi
président de la république je ne serai
pas le chef de la majorité je ne
recevrai pas les parlementaires de la
majorité à l'elysée moi président de la
république je ne traiterai pas mon
premier liste de collaborateurs
mois président de la république je ne
participerai pas des collectes de fonds
pour mon propre parti dans un hôtel
parisien - président de la république je
ferais fonctionner la justice de manière
indépendante je ne nommerai pas les
membres du parquet alors que l'avis du
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
n'a pas été dans ce sens moi président
de la république je n'aurai pas la
prétention nommait les directeurs des
chaînes de télévision publiques je
laisserai ça à des instances
indépendantes mois président de la
république je ferais en sorte que mon
comportement soit à chaque instant
exemplaire mois président de la
république j'aurais aussi à coeur de ne
pas avoir un statut pénal du chef de
l'état je le ferais réformer de façon à
ce que si et des actes antérieurs à ma
prise de fonction venait à être
contestées je puisse dans certaines
conditions me rendre à la convocation de
tel ou tel magistrat ou m'expliquer
devant un certain nombre d'instances
mois président de la république je
constituerai un gouvernement qui sera
paritaire autant de femmes que d'hommes
mois président de la république il y
aura un code de déontologie pour les
ministres qui ne pourraient pas rentrer
dans un conflit d'intérêts mois
président de la république les ministres
ne pourront pas cumuler leurs fonctions
avec un mandat local
parce que je considère qu'il devrait se
consacrer pleinement à leurs tâches mois
président de la république je ferais un
acte de décentralisation parce que je
pense que les collectivités locales ont
besoin d'un nouveau souffle de nouvelles
compétences de nouvelles libertés -
président de la république je ferais en
sorte que les partenaires sociaux
puissent être considéré aussi bien les
organisations professionnelles que les
syndicats et que nous puissions avoir
régulièrement une discussion pour savoir
ce qui relève de la loi ce qui relève de
la négociation mois président de la
république j'engagerai de grands débats
on a évoqué celui de l'énergie et il est
légitime qu'il puisse y avoir sur ces
questions-là de grand débat citoyen -
président de la république j'introduirai
la représentation proportionnelle pour
les élections législatives pour les
élections non pas celle de 2012 mais
celle de 2017 parce que je pense qu'il
est bon que l'ensemble des sensibilités
politiques soient représentés -
président de la république j'essaierai
d'avoir de la hauteur de vue pour fixer
les grandes orientations les grandes
impulsions mais en même temps je ne
m'occuperai pas de tout et j'aurai
toujours le souci de la proximité avec
les français j'avais évoqué
présidence normale yann est normal quand
on est président de la république
puisque les conditions sont
exceptionnelles le mot de traverse une
crise majeure en tout cas l'europe il y
à des conflits dans le monde sur la
planète khaldoun enjeux de
l'environnement du réchauffement
climatique bien sûr que le président
doit être à la hauteur de ces sujets là
mais il doit aussi être proche du peuple
être capable de le comprendre
nicolas sarkozy vous avez trois minutes
de retard oui monsieur hollande vous
avez parlé
sans doute doit être désagréable bon
endroit d'un président normal je vous
dis à la fonction de président de la
république c'est pas une fonction
normale et la situation que nous
connaissons c'est pas une situation
normale
votre normalité elle ne le parle hauteur
des enjeux
parce que pour postuler cette fonction
là je ne pense pas que général de gaulle
françois mitterrand valéry giscard
d'estaing jacques chirac georges
pompidou c'était à proprement parler des
hommes normaux vous venez de nous faire
un beau discours on en avait la larme à
l'oeil mais c'est le même françois
hollande qui quand il s'enflamme en
immense françois mitterrand dans les
meetings dit je ne garderais aucun des
magistrats aucun des policiers vous avez
l'interprétation vous n'avez pas d'art
ayant visiblement travaillé est ce que
m'avait écouté par nicolas sarkozy vous
avez une phrase une une luxueux donné
l'émoi plaisir donné l'émoi je vous
laisse en fait rêver je veux bien qu un
courrier que je suis qui les suivent ça
que j'ai jamais parce que je n'ai jamais
vous annoncez de telfrance avait dit que
tous ceux qui avaient travaillé avec la
majorité sortante puisque pour lyon
c'est déjà fait vous ne travaillerai pas
avec eux vous parlez de l'indépendance
de la justice c'est une plaisanterie
monsieur hollande vous avez été aux
côtés de françois mitterrand qui
présidait le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature qui a supprimé la
présidence du conseil de magistrature
par le président de la république c'est
moi qui préside aujourd'hui la préside
le conseil supérieur de la magistrature
cette procureur général près la cour de
cassation et le président de la cour de
cassation je ne vous ai pas attendu pour
cela vous voulez que les parquetiers
soit nommé avec avis conforme du csm je
suis d'accord et je tiens pas à effet
bonjour camionneurs non ce n'est pas
exigée vous devez j'ai suivi j'ai suivi
de cette nomination cette nomination de
la 100g chiant avis du csm 7 notamment
manalich 9,7 notamment madame fichiers
ski parce que j'ai congés et fait nommer
le type au procureur de la république de
paris le directeur de cabinet du garde
des sceaux ça ne s'était jamais avec
l'accord du csa ne s'était jamais fait
monsieur hollande monsieur hollande
avant d'insulter cet homme je ne suis le
siège si c'est pas l'homme ne sait
encore monsieur la question le csm at il
donné son accord il sait bien plus de
deskom et c'est vous qui est prodigieux
6 évidemment ces présidents qui fait et
le gouvernement et ça ne s'est jamais
cet été alors nicolas sarkozy poursuit
son excellent comme les fraises qu'une
liste tant de charme le ccem a donné son
accord pour cet homme d'une intégrité
absolument remarquable vous dites que
vous serez un homme de rassemblement
vous ne cessez de parler au peuple de
gauche au parti socialiste vous ne
cessez d'être entouré par le parti
socialiste par monsieur mélenchon et par
madame joly vous êtes un homme qui ne
n'allait pas dans les réunions de partis
mais votre état major de campagne est
composée du code socialiste pardon b je
ne suis pas président de la république
est ce que vous avez reçu comme
président de la république les
parlementaires de la majorité à l'elysée
oui ou non oui bien sûr donc ouverte la
porte est comme un chef de parti est ce
que monsieur mitterrand ne vous recevez
n'arrive jamais il n'y avait pas le
petit déjeuner des énormes enjeux pas
menacée je ne parle pas des petits
déjeuners je parle des réunions monsieur
l'ensemble de la majorité à l'elysée sur
le web est tenu des réunions sur la
collecte de fonds échéant à l'hôtel
bristol ou pas n'ont jamais sûr j'ai
jamais avec monsieur roux n'avait été à
l'hôtel bristol pour eux non non non non
pour connecter des fois non je suis la
vérité je vous répondrais dit la vérité
je suis à m'étais beaucoup et monsieur
lance vous n'étiez pas convoqué par
monsieur phénomène différent je souhaite
à nos idéaux je parle de vous je lui
répondrais vous n'étiez pas convoqué par
monsieur mitterrand toutes les semaines
pour un petit déjeuner ou un hangar du
parti socialiste ont rappelé qu'ils ne
passaient pas il ne petit déjeuner pas
tout les sites à fait différente à
inzell tout à fait différent d'inviter
tous les parlements pertes et tous les
parlementaires j'ai invité uniquement de
loi parlementaire uniquement de droite
plusieurs fois je voulais je vous donne
les dates ce n'est pas les à vos actes
j'ai invité tous les le mans terre de la
majorité et de l'opposition
plusieurs reprises les parlementaires de
votre parti est celui ci et si il y
avait les centres il avait enfin de
votre père gerry d'été vous vous êtes
comporté comme un chef de n'a jamais
jamais mais vous avez également chargé
cm à des chiots de collecte de fonds via
l'hôtel bristol jamais je me suis prêtée
à cela je le regrette mais vous avez une
préférence partisane martial et vous en
payez aujourd'hui les conséquences sur
lens est un mensonge encore jamais
utilisé ce mot mais le sud est très
précisément qu'est ce que j'ai posé le
précisément monsieur mitterrand avait
nommé un ancien demi heure je vous parle
de vous monsieur monsieur long sur la
cour des comptes j'ai nommé un député
socialiste vrai ou pas à la tête de la
cour des comptes c'est une présidence
partisane j'ai autorisé la cour des
comptes à contrôler tous les ans les
comptes de l'elysée
mes prédécesseurs ne l'ont jamais fait
c'est une présidence partisane j'ai
nommé au conseil constitutionnel un
ancien collaborateur de monsieur
mitterrand monsieur charasse c'est une
présidence partisane j'ai nommé à la
présidence de la sncf
l'ancien directeur de cabinet de madame
aubry c'est une présidence partisane
j'ai nommé dans les gouvernements aux
côtés de monsieur fillon des
personnalités de gauche qui n'ont pas
toujours rendu c'est une présidence
partizan ont compris quand même quand
c'est une fusée merci de votre arrogance
non cela gêne terrain c'est une
présidence partisane j'ai donné j'ai
donné la présidence de la commission des
finances de l'assemblée nationale avoue
qu'il avait levé c'est pas vous qui
connaissez pas c'est pas vous qui ne
m'est encore le président de la
commission des finances vers l'assemblée
nationale c'était dans mon prochain en
2000 c'est long les parlements dans mon
nous avons fait la même chose aux
sermons projet de 2007 j'avais dit si je
suis élu président de la république le
président de la commission des finances
à l'assemblée ne viendra pas de la
majorité au parlement argent pas d'un
partout monsieur hollande dans des
filets ministère l'essai en toutes les
préfectures c'est moi toutes les allées
se termine c'est price chacun termine
souffrance c y compris dans les
établissements bancaires qui dépendent
de vous monsieur plus ou moins monsieur
y compris à dexia vous avez nommé mister
minit si je terminais et c'est ce que je
pense et ça c'est amans soult compris
pour la magie c'est une calomnie vous
êtes vraiment gaz mis en exergue en dise
exactement ce que vous avez là président
sur la commission membres de la
magistrature c'est incontestable alors
nicolas sarkozy vos réponses et on va
réussir la commission des finances à la
politique étranger la majorité
républicaine et c'est la présidence la
plus prestigieuse c'est elle qui
certifie les comptes de l'état
c'est un député socialiste il est vrai
que vous avez imiter à juste titre ce
que nous avons fait au sénat mais
comment osez vous dire comment osez vous
dire que j'ai une présidence partisane
alors que dans la majorité on m'a
reproché un nombre incalculable de fois
de faire la part trop belle à ceux qui
m'avaient combattu à ceux qui n'avaient
pas mes idées parce que je considère je
considère moi que lorsqu'on est
président de la république on est
président aussi de ceux qui n'ont pas
voté pour vous j'ai fait un effort
d'ouverture qu'aucun autre avant moi
n'avait fait aucun autre et que vous ne
serez pas capable de faire et que jamais
un socialiste n'avait fait avant nous
c'est jamais et ben si vous le faites si
un jour vous êtes élu eh bien je me
donnerai les français parce que alors ce
sont les français qui vont décider j'ai
vu des mois qui je vais brûler dit au
revoir hier je vais prendre des
engagements et que c'était pas très
risqué je vais prendre francis
d'engagement devant les français vous
avez une note françois hollande et puis
on enchaîne si je deviens le prochain
président de la république
je ne nommerai personne sans que les
commissions parlementaires en dessine
non pas à la majorité de deux tiers
contre à la 2 majorité de deux tiers
pour ce qui veut dire que l'opposition
sera directement associés impliquez pas
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui ce sera
avec l'opposition que nous nommerons ces
personnalités deuxièmement si je deviens
le prochain président de la république
je renoncerai au statut pénal du chef de
l'état en organisant différemment la
protection pour les actes de la
présidence il est normal qu'il y ait une
immunité pour tous les actes commis
antérieurement il n'y aura plus aucune
protection rien je fais un autre
engagement le dernier à dire que sur la
justice ça sera le conseil supérieur de
la majoration modifié d'ailleurs pour
que il se soit composé de
majoritairement de magistrats qui puisse
nommer les magistrats du siège et les
magistrats du parquet pour qu'il n'y ait
aucune intervention sur les parquets par
rapport à telle ou telle affaire bien
sûr aussi lille l'audiovisuel public ce
ne sera plus le président de la
république qui nommera ce sera une
commission par
un
mot là-dessus parce que ressentent à
panser leurs plaies nicolas sark d'abord
les 60 premières nominations j'ai voulu
que les commissions compétentes du
parlement puisse donner leur avis et
puissent bloquer les 60 premières
nominations pas un président de la
république avant - visa voyez que je
vous rappelle mitterrand le mans son
directeur de cabinet à la tête d'elf
nommant sur directeur de cabinet à la
tête de canal plus et vous venez nous
donner des leçons qui était président de
canal+ chaîne de télévision monsieur
rochelais et les directeurs de
cabinet des témoins il est témoin qui
devait plus dur est devant dell ce
monsieur ménage ou monsieur je vous cite
aussi lorsque vous avez nommés non moi
je vous dis nourriture sauf que moi je
fais une rupture par rapport à nous et
je devais par rapport à donner ses
leçons moi je n'ai rupture cieux je
n'accepterai pas permis s'était terminée
lis que je vous s'échouer allié à 60 60
rien ne sera toléré le sheikh milliards
icône à ce vieux monsieur hollande oui
je ne prendrai pas de leçons d'un parti
politique qui a voulu avec enthousiaste
se rassembler derrière dominique strauss
mais je me doutais que j'arrive y est
franchement je me doutais vous arrivez
en parle 1 7 me prennent part les 60
premiers rozema mentionné dominique
strauss kahn à la tête du fmi oui je
connaissais moins bien que vous mais je
ne cause il a voulu en tout cas vous
connaissez connaissez suffisamment pour
le 2-0 de fond vous le coni s'ils
parlent que des siens sur d'autres biens
pour le verger voulons dire mais j'ai
instruit à venir sur
il ne paraît pas un autre aujourd'hui
mais suffisamment ce qui me soland luce
j'ai voulu que l'opposition ait des
responsabilités
et franchement quand on a découvert le
vrai visage de monsieur strauss kahn ont
été étonnés mais que vous vous osiez me
dire vous ne le connaissiez pas c'est un
peu dur mais je connaissais sa vie puis
les cheveux ternes les ché quand vous
voulez vous je la connaisse comme nous
vous le chat connaissent vous avez des
informations que je n'avais pas 11
pilotes c'est pas pour ce pilote vous
avez des informations vous non bon ben
moi savoir comment je n'aurais je prends
mes moyens je pense qu'en quelle
procédure vous je pense que vous
fréquentez vous pensez tout le monde et
la vie privée de vaud de vos
collaborateurs ou de vos amis - bah
franchement je ne la connais pas
monsieur monsieur hollande ne vous
défausser pas à ce point là sur le
statut pénal du chef de l'état et ces
gens n'est en rien de chose qu'on aborde
s'il voulait le changer j'en ai hérité
monsieur pas changé j'en ai hérité
l'avez vous changer il a été changé en
2007 à la veille ont changé aux missions
mais j'en ai hérité moi je l'échangerais
il n'y a pas un gouvernement où il n'y a
pas un statut particulier pour chef
d'état mais à quelque chose que les
français doivent savoir c'est quand un
président de la république et président
de la république toutes les procédures
le délai de prescription est interrompue
ce qui fait qu'une fois la présidence
terminé chacun rendez compte on l'a bien
vu avec jacques chirac il est vrai qu'on
ne l'a pas vu avec françois mitterrand
non on l'a bien vu avec jacques chirac
il est 23 fois religion messieurs va pas
on va y aller de l'avant sur le dos
c'était la nuit dont j'ai hérité on va
on va clore ce débat dans un quart
d'heure le temps tout de même d'aborder
au moins un ou deux sujets de politique
étrangère en premier lieu celui qui
concerne directement la france nous
avons des troupes en afghanistan
un retrait est programmée mais vous
n'êtes pas d'accord sur le calendrier
françois hollande vous avez une minute
trente de retard quel est exactement
votre position sur ce retrait des
troupes françaises en afghanistan la
décision d'envoyer des troupes
françaises en afghanistan ou plus
exactement de décider d'une intervention
militaire en afghanistan a été prise
conjointement par lionel jospin et par
jacques chirac en 2001 suite aux
attentats de new york ensuite la mission
a progressivement évolué je rappelle
qu'elle était destinée à capturer ben
laden et abattre le régime
à l'époque des talibans
en 2007 quand nicolas sarkozy vous êtes
présentés aux suffrages vous avez dit
que vous n'envisagez pas de maintenir
très longtemps les troupes en
afghanistan en 2008 une nouvelle fois
vous avez changé d'avis et vous avez
envoyé des troupes supplémentaires en
afghanistan et pour une autre mission
d'intervention directe c'est une
responsabilité qui vous revient et je
considère que maintenant et serait dû
être fait beaucoup plus tôt les troupes
françaises n'ont pas à rester plus
longtemps en afghanistan quand il s'est
passé là c'est une terrible tragédie au
début de l'année vous avez anticiper le
retrait l'aviez prévu fin 2014 avait
décidé fin 2013 moi je considère sans
prendre le moindre risque pour nos
troupes car j'y serai très attentif
qu'il convient de les retirer des
troupes combattantes fin 2012 et donc
j'annoncerai cette décision si les
français me font confiance dimanche dès
le sommet de chicago le sommet de l'otan
pour que nous engagions ce processus je
le ferai en bonne intelligence avec nos
alliés d'autres pays se sont déjà
retirés et je le ferai aussi sans
prendre le moindre risque par rapport à
notre il ya aussi le matériel qu'il
conviendra d'évacuer et sacrera sur
d'autres pour le matériel plus de temps
voilà ma position nicolas joseph brandt
personnes là encore avec effet de
surprise
je ne cesse de le dire depuis des mois
je le dis aujourd'hui comme candidat je
souhaite le faire comme président notre
réponse nicolas sarkozy bon en
afghanistan nos soldats ont fait un
travail absolument extraordinaire
j'aurais été à la place de lionel jospin
et de jacques chirac à l'époque j'aurais
fait la pris la même décision
je vous rappelle que ces talibans couper
les mains des petites filles qui
mettaient du vernis à ongles je vous
rappelle que ces talibans avaient décidé
que les petites finir et plus à l'école
et l'afghanistan est en train de devenir
le repaire du terrorisme mondial nous ne
sommes pas seuls là bas il y à 56 p dont
nos amis américains mais la plupart de
nos partenaires européens et c'est
ensemble que nous avons décidé d'une
stratégie qui consiste à aider le peuple
afghan à se libérer de cette gangrène
terroristes et assumer seul c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'organisation
la gestion de la sécurité de leur pays
la france quand je suis arrivé avait la
responsabilité de kaboul nous avons
laissé la responsabilité de kaboul aux
forces afghanes la france avait de
région assure aux billets à kapisa la
france n'a plus qu'une région
progressivement nous nous désengageons
mais en bon ordre
parce que j'ai la responsabilité de la
parole de la france donc de l'honneur de
la france le président obama a décidé il
ya trois ans ce qu'on a appelé la search
c'est à dire l'envoi de renforts pour
éradiquer le terrorisme ils ont trouvé
ben laden pour stabiliser l'afghanistan
ensemble avec le président obama et nos
alliés nous avons décidé qu'à la fin de
2013 le président baba dièye me dire il
n'y aurait plus d'action combattants des
forces alliées partir en 2012 c'est
d'abord techniquement impossible compte
tenu du matériel que nous avons là-bas
et des problèmes de sécurité que nous
avons là-bas partir en 2012 ça serait
parjure par rapport à l'engagement avec
nos partenaires qui nous demandent que
nous partions ensemble en 2013 la france
n'est pas seule la france a des alliés
la france ait des amis la france a un
honneur partir comme cela pour quoi
parce qu'on veut plus battre c'est à
dire laisser les talibans ne pas finir
le travail que nous avons engagé avec
nos alliés donc si je suis président de
la république pour les cinq années qui
viennent en bon accord avec nos alliés
nous laisserons la responsabilité de la
sécurité de l'afghanistan aux afghans à
la fin 2013 et notre forme de
coopération deviendra plus économiques
universitaires sociales éducatives comme
il est un des points de vue différents
les autres points jason en 2014 les
américains envisagent de se retirer mais
partiellement et l'addition vous avez
prise est de vous retirer avant les
amériques non c'est en accord avec eux
et je suis taquin la gestion nous avait
prise c'est de vous retirer à venteux et
la décision que je prendrai tout en
rendant hommage à nos soldats qui ont
sacrifié leur vie 83 d'entre eux et qui
pour des familles ont été durement
éprouvées c'est de considérer que
l'émission est terminée parce que la
prolonger aujourd'hui alors même que
vous avez évoqué notre retrait d'une
d'une région et pour l'autre où nous ne
sommes plus intervenants directs nous
formons je considère que la mission est
achevée et qui ne sert donc à rien
d'exposer davantage nos soldats qui ont
fait un travail formidable et utile même
si chacun le sait l'établissement
continue de frapper compris aujourd'hui
même kaboul donc il n'y a aucune raison
de maintenir notre eau au delà de 2012
s'il doit y avoir des difficultés
matérielles j'y répondrai c'est
effectivement un problème d'évacuation
je ne prendrai aucun risque pour nos
soldats mais je dirais très fermement à
nos alliés ils le savent déjà puisqu'il
regarde notre élection aussi que cette
décision elle sera conforme à nos
principes
cohérente par rapport à ma position
travail n'est pas terminé puisqu'il nous
reste une région à transmettre à nos
amis afghans et je n'ai pas l'intention
d'accepter que l'armée française après
tous ces sacrifices parts avant que le
travail ne soit terminée nous l'avons
fait à kaboul nous l'avons fait dans une
première région nous avons une dernière
région l'armée française tiendra ses
engagements et la france tiendra ses
parents alors la menace terroriste elle
plane également dans le maghreb
islamique avec la montée en puissance
d'al qaïda dans les pays du sahel comme
le mali le niger la mauritanie ou encore
au yémen et en somalie huit otages
français sont détenus dans cette zone
que proposez-vous pour leur libération
monsieur hollande nous avons neuf
compatriotes qui sont retenus comme
otages 8 vous avez raison dans cette
partie là de l'afrique la zone celle qui
a été considérable en déstabilise à la
fois par rapport à ce qui se passe
ou ce qui s'est passé en libye ce qui se
passe au nigeria ce qui se passe en
mauritanie il y à là
effectivement des réseaux qui se sont
constitués et aqmi qui s'est installée
en alliance avec d'autres nous devons
aider les pays le mali aujourd'hui qui
est frappée par une déstabilisation
nous devons aider la mauritanie nous
devons avoir aussi avec le niger une
politique qui soit très active alors que
faire par rapport aux otages moi je n'ai
pas les informations que peut-être
monsieur sarkozy peut nous livrer mais
je ne crois pas que ce soit sa
responsabilité ici il faut être très
prudent je lui demanderai rien là dessus
parce que je considère que ça fait
partie des prérogatives du chef de
l'état et des autorités publiques de
savoir qu'est ce qu'il est possible de
faire pour la libération des otages
j'étais l'époque premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste associer c'était le
gouvernement raffarin par rapport à des
otages qui étaient détenus en irak et je
le remercier parce que je conviens que
c'était bien que l'opposition puisse en
savoir pas tous mais en savoir
suffisamment pour comprendre ce qui se
passe est donc là dessus je ne doute pas
qu au lendemain d'élections
présidentielles toutes les informations
nous seront données pour que nous
puissions travailler à la libération de
ces otages et surtout aussi au delà de
ce qu'il convient de faire pour leurs
familles et pour eux même de permettre
la stabilisation de cette partie du
monde ces parties de l'afrique qui
risque d'être un foyer terroriste de
très grande ampleur nicolas sarkozy et
puis on va conclure bon dans cette
partie du monde nous avons d'abord une
bonne nouvelle avec l'élection qui s'est
très bien passé au sénégal avec
l'élection du président macky sall nous
avons une mauvaise nouvelle avec ce qui
s'est passé est que président att au
mali où il n'y avait aucune raison qui
ce coup d'état la première priorité
c'est que nos amis maliens comprennent
qu'ils doivent organiser l'élection
présidentielle démocratique rien ne
pourra se faire dans cette partie du
monde
si nous n'avons pas l'élection d'un
gouvernement démocratique mais on a
besoin du mali qui est un pays
considérables et qui est miné à la fois
par la rébellion touarègue et par le
problème d'aquin s'agissant de la
mauritanie et du niger les élections s'y
sont déroulés de façon parfaitement
transparent que faire renforcer notre
coopération militaire et économique avec
le niger la mauritanie le sénégal et le
mali quand il aura un gouvernement
démocratique parce que ces pays il faut
bien le comprendre non pas la structure
étatique pour faire face à une zone qui
est considérable il faut voir que la
partie où se trouve à tenir le désert le
seul c'est trois fois la france ils
n'ont pas les moyens aériens ils n'ont
pas les moyens hélicoptère ils n'ont pas
les moyens de renseignement pour nos
compatriotes français décryptage il y a
un problème dans cette région le
problème c'est la confiance que nous
devons mettre dans le travail avec
l'algérie qui est la puissance régionale
et qu'allegri
de l'ensemble des données du problème la
france et l'ancien pays colonial
donc la france ne peut pas intervenir
directement la france te plains
intervenir qu'en soutien avec ces pays
mais il faut pousser ces pays algérie
niger mali mauritanie sénégal à
travailler ensemble et que la france ait
d'autres pays les aide matériellement et
techniquement
s'agissant de nos otages comme l'a dit
monsieur hollande on ne peut pas en
parler dans une émission de cette nature
chaque cas est un cas particulier
nous sommes face à une montée du
terrorisme est la seule chose qu'on
puisse dire aujourd'hui c'est demander à
nos compatriotes de ne pas aller dans
cette partie du monde y compris s'il
travaille dans l'humanitaire parce que
les conditions de sécurité ne peuvent
pas être assumés par l'état français
bien nous arrivons au terme de cette
émission nous avons essayé d'aborder le
plus de sujets possibles ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas mais j'espère que
ceux qui nous ont regardés auront été
instruites cette confrontation nous
allons vous demander à chacun d'entre
vous une conclusion françois hollande
vous avez une minute vingt de retard
donc vous demander une conclusion en
trois minutes pas beaucoup plus s'il
vous plaît et puis ce sera nicolas
sarkozy c'est avoue françois
ce débat a été utile il a montré des
différences
sur les politiques économiques sociales
fiscales nous n'avons pas le même projet
le bilan de nicolas sarkozy
a été décrit comme étant
particulièrement lourd je me souviens de
ce qu'il disait en 2007 dans ce même
débat face à madame royal 10 et voilà je
voulais être jugé sur les résultats
je veux le plein emploi je veux le
progrès du pouvoir d'achat je veux la
maîtrise de l'immigration je veux la
sécurité encore améliorer je veux la
compétitivité
chacun jugera ce qui a été fait ce qui
n'a pas été fait moi je veux changer
changer de politique
chargé de méthodes changent et de
conception de la république
changer aussi de démarche par rapport à
l'ensemble de la société française
je veux aussi qu'il y ait sur le plan
européen
un changement d'orientation
donc le choix est simple est-ce que les
français veulent continuer une politique
qui n'a pas marché et qui en plus ouvrir
et d'autres risques sur le temps de
travail sur la protection sociale sur la
fiscalité je veux pas que mes
compatriotes prennent ce risque là mais
c'est à eux d'en décider ou changer
changer ça veut dire faire du
redressement de notre pays la grande
cause
redressement productif redressement
industriel
redressement économique redressement
moral je veux que nous puissions nous
retrouver sur la seule valeur qui vaille
la jeunesse je veux que l'éducation soit
la grande priorité parce que c'est pour
la jeunesse que je veux m'engager pour
le prochain quinquennat la seconde
exigence et la justice ahlam hockey tout
au long de ces cinq dernières années
je la rétablir est partout je veux être
jugé sur
les décisions que j'aurais prise en
fonction de ce critère jeu juste ou pas
et enfin je veux rassembler rassembler
non pas simplement les socialistes ou la
gauche comme vous l'avez dit rassembler
tous ceux qui sont attachés aux valeurs
de la république qui veulent que la
france rayonne partout dans le monde qui
veulent que la france soit fière
d'elle-même qui veulent que les jeunes
français puissent porter un idéal je
n'écarte personne jeu de repousses
personnes je ne stigmatise aucune force
qui existe nous aurons besoin de toutes
les forces de la france voilà le choix
qui est posée pour dimanche continuer
avec vous nicolas sarkozy ou changer il
n'y a pas de peur à installer que les
français n'aient pas peur il n'y aura
pas la spéculation que vous avez réclamé
il n'y aura pas la comparaison avec
l'espagne aura pas l'invasion par des
cohortes étrangères non les lois de la
république seront appliquées la gestion
sur un scène les finances publiques
seront rétablis et l'économie sera
activée voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire moi je veux pas porter une peur
même pas la peur de votre propre
reconduction ce que je souhaite c'est
que les français reprennent confiance et
espoir alors nicolas sarkozy françois
hollande avait commencé ce débat c'est à
vous de le conclure vous avez deux
minutes moi je veux m'adresser à tous
les français et qui n'ont pas voté pour
moi premier tour remerciant ceux les
quelques 10 millions qui ont voté pour
moi
je parlais à ceux qui ont voté pour
marine le pen
moi je n'ai pas pris une pince à linge
dont bush et le dé monsieur hollande et
je ne les aurais pas fait de leçon de
morale parce que voyez vous je ne fais
pas de leçons de morale à des gens qui
vivent dans les quartiers aux jeunes vis
pas ou qui mettent leurs enfants dans
des écoles je ne vis pas pour moi il
n'ya pas des sous citoyens mais pour moi
non plus ils ont eu le droit d'exprimer
le vote quelques décès et joyeux à
égalité de droits règles s'il vous plaît
monsieur hollande je prévois conclusion
leur parler sans être interrompu en leur
disant vous avez exprimé un choix ce
n'est pas de tes pas le mien je vous
respecte je vous considère j'ai entendu
votre demande de nation de frontières
d'authenticité d'autorité de fermeté
je veux parler aux électeurs de françois
bayrou également ils ont bien le droit
n'ont pas fait mon choix je vais leur
dire une chose
le coeur de la campagne de françois
bayrou c'est la réduction des déficits
son premier engagement c'est la règle
d'or monsieur hollande la refusent parce
qu'il ne veut s'enfermer dans aucune
règle vous avez bien compris c'est des
paroles qui vole les engagements c'est
pour plus tard la règle d'or je la ferai
adapté
s'il le faut par le référendum car je
considère qu'un pays qui ne rembourse
pas sa dette qui ne réduit pas ses
déficits qui ne diminue pas assez défend
c'est un pays libre je veux parler à
tous ceux qui sont abstenus alors disant
voilà ne laissez pas les autres voter à
votre place quel que soit votre choix ça
doit être non pas un vote d'humeur mais
un vote pour cinq ans la question n'est
pas celle de monsieur hollande je je je
ou de monsieur sarkozy la question c'est
vous les français quelle direction doit
pour la france quel avenir pour nos
enfants nous sommes dans un monde
dangereux un monde difficile où il faut
savoir prendre des décisions
tenir un cap et assumée assumer sa
responsabilité
j'ai beaucoup réfléchi avant d'être
candidat si je le suis c'est parce que
j'ai la passion de la france et que je
souhaite vous conduire dans ce monde
difficile pour les cinq années qui
viennent merci à tous les deux on est à
égalité parfaite du temps de parole
merci beaucoup d'avis pour ce débat
merci à toutes les équipes qui se sont
mobilisés sur nos deux antennes pour la
réussite de cette soirée exceptionnelle
à quatre jours du scrutin bonne soirée à
tous merci à vous merci
[Musique]